so uh the other day we learned that the
third trial a bench trial in the January
6 case was an acquittal because this
dude was like yo your honor this cop led
me in and the judge was like look at
that the cop let him in and then there
you go case dismissed this guy's
acquitted of basically everything well
of course men in the left were still
pretending like that never happened and
now we have another story so you know
those guys that were accused of trying
to kidnap Whitmer yeah well uh two of
them have been acquitted and the others
have received a mistrial so that whole
narrative is imploding The Narrative
there is basically that these guys were
claiming they were just stoned and
talking BS and these feds were like yeah
yeah it's all real it's all real and
then brought that to a criminal trial
but of course I don't know if it really
matters because the media got their
Narrative of the evil far right trying
to kidnap a governor which turns out to
be mostly bunk so we'll talk about all
that and uh we have this tweet it was
from um the guys over at mythicist it's
a bill more episode from I think 2019
where Dennis Prager is saying that the
left is lying men can't menstruate and
everyone on the show laughs at him and
Bill Maher says you're crazy so uh
considering the laws that are being
passed we have the the governor of
Alabama just signed a law Banning
medical intervention for children if
they are deemed trans by a doctor
I want to show up proof that Dennis
Prager I want to show proof Prager was
right and uh uh I think we gotta I think
we gotta call out Bill Maher a little
bit look I know a lot of people are
happy that he calls at the left when he
does but if the dude actually did
cursory Google searches on half this
stuff
it would be a whole nother ball game
you'd have people being like wow you
know I watched that guy and he's
informed me but he doesn't a week after
Covington Bill Maher still got the story
wrong when everyone else had already
corrected so no leeway uh from me on
what's going on with him but we'll talk
about all that layoffs are expected at
CNN and other networks because it's a
big merger food riots and fuel riots in
Peru already because uh expect things to
get pretty bad so uh we'll talk about
that and then maybe we'll get to It Will
Smith has been banned from the Oscars
but that's not really what I really care
about what I care about is a story that
apparently his wife was like saying she
cried when she got married because she
didn't want to marry him oh yeah talk
about it horrible thing to say about
your husband the video that's it yeah
we'll get into all of this and joining
us to talk about this is Oren McIntyre
how's it going man hey man thanks for
having me appreciate it do you want to
introduce yourself yeah absolutely uh I
run a YouTube channel uh Oren McIntyre
you can just search it up over there I
do a lot of uh explaining of political
Theory and then interviews you know news
and the day that type of stuff too but
it's mostly about political Theory and
then I make memes on Twitter which is
what a lot of people know me from well
there we go you want to do me a favor
can you throw that on the shelf behind
you
there you go also um Magic the Gathering
player if I'm not mistake we were
talking a little bit Oh see now you're
outing me but yeah
that's true
together Sheamus is instantly offended
that's right I'm gonna get out of here
all of you a bunch of nerds which
questions it's not just witchcraft it's
nerds you guys are nerds you know as I
tell people you know my parents didn't
let me read Harry Potter not because of
the the Demonic elements they just
didn't want me to be a nerd they want to
be one of those Harry Potter kids
they're like this kid doesn't need any
help getting bullied all right then read
Harry Potter bro based on this
generation I'd argue you were more
likely to get bullied before not reading
it the bully would be like what did you
think of Snape I know they're like
they're like what house are you this
guy's not a Gryffindor I was like oh
shut up
um I am Seamus goggle and I run a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes we
do animated political satire we upload a
new video every Thursday we just
uploaded one this past Thursday I think
you guys are really going to enjoy it we
might we might get wild and upload two
next week I don't know we'll see we'll
see he speaks the truth uh Ian Crossing
what's up everybody catch you soon yeah
I'm very excited uh Sheamus's uh Freedom
twins is awesome and we're gonna be in
Nashville next week and Aaron is
fantastic it's gonna be a great evening
let's get going yeah actually right
after the show tonight we're running out
the door driving straight to Nashville
we've got the mobile command center
already on the way and we're going to be
parked in their parking lot for the next
week with a variety of their talent and
there's a whole lot of crazy stuff we're
planning we'll see how much we can
actually pull off but it'll be a lot of
fun we're gonna have a lot of people
from the daily wire on the show next
week it's going to be Tim guest live
from the daily wire in Nashville so uh
we'll we'll uh we'll see you then but
for now let's jump over to timcast.com
before we get started become a member
help support our work we have this story
that we're going to get into in a second
about these two guys these two uh people
accused who have been found not guilty
as a member you are helping support all
of that great journalism and you will
also get access to exclusive segments of
this podcast Monday through Thursday at
8pm we have a huge library of content so
you definitely check out all of that
stuff you'll you'll love a lot of these
videos not so family friendly lots of
swearing yesterday we had a deep
discussion with Andrew Clavin on
religion which is very very interesting
I get to leave a little bit early but it
was it was a fun conversation so don't
forget get to join at timcast.com smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's read this the first story here
from timcast.com
breaking two men accused of Governor
Whitmer kidnapping plot found not guilty
two others received mistrial the jury
deliberated for five days following a
two-week trial they're going to mention
on April 8th a jury found Daniel Harris
not guilty of one charge of kidnapping
conspiracy one count of conspiracy to
use a weapon of mass destruction one
count of possession of an unregistered
destructive device one counterposition
of an unregistered short-barreled rifle
Harris was the only one of the four
defendants who testified in his own
defense Brandon caserta who was charged
with one kind of kidnapping conspiracy
was also found not guilty the jury
declared a mistrial on the charges
brought against Barry Croft Jr and Adam
Fox the charges include kidnapping
conspiracy conspiracy to use a weapon of
mass destruction and possession of an
unregistered destructive device the US
government claimed the men had been
planning to kidnap Whitmer at her
vacation home prior to the 2020 election
and arrested them in October of 2020.
all four men have denied the
government's accusations didn't it turn
out that um like the majority of people
involved in this were feds or some kind
of informant yeah like it wasn't even
like an actual plot let me show you this
from The Daily Mail they say how the how
undercover FBI agents infiltrated
militia group Wolverine Watchmen to try
to take down Gretchen Whitman whitmer's
kidnappers they say what do they call it
stoned talk they said they said it was
nothing but stoned talk that the
government turned into a real conspiracy
wow schweers and Bates both testified at
trial so so look without getting into
you know hashing out the entirety of the
trial the story has been I think for
most people fairly obvious as soon as
they said yeah it was a bunch of FBI
agents that seem to have been
orchestrating the whole thing and then
blaming these guys who are bumbling
along for the FBI's own plan along with
this story and the story about January 6
where the third trial this guy was like
the cops opened the door and let me in
the judge went yeah the video shows the
cops open the door and let you in not
guilty the media narrative on what
Insurrection the rise of the far right
it's all uh all just bunk BS bunk bunk
BS panel would you agree yeah I mean I
would tend to agree the entire narrative
started falling apart a couple months
ago and honestly when it was first
reported as a story I remember watching
my television regrettably checking
Twitter saying wow this is really
horrible and for the people who are
actually committing legitimate acts of
violence and breaking in yes that's bad
I think we all agree that's criminal but
I should have known known that the media
was spinning that's trying to make it
out to be something it wasn't they
started to refer to it as an
Insurrection which is interesting
because it's an Insurrection where
basically no one who went the vast
majority of people didn't have weapons
on them to try to overthrow the
government just a very bizarre narrative
but I think people were too afraid to
question it because they didn't want to
seem in support of it because our our
media spent so much time calling it a
terroristic Act
I just tweeted out earlier that I don't
trust screenshots pictures or video
anymore I don't trust it man I don't
trust the narrative I don't trust the
media it's going to be even hard for me
to trust people face to face which I
really don't anyway but man I don't want
to get tainted on Humanity here but I am
not I'm not buying any of this crap
anymore I hear you but you're not
necessarily getting tainted on Humanity
I think it's okay to acknowledge that
known Liars are known are known liars
and you shouldn't listen to them without
having a pessimistic view of humans in
general I think I think you shouldn't
trust cartoonists
and now I would disagree I I think well
in most instances that's probably
correct but there are a few good apples
yeah I think that's exactly what an
animator would say I know right if you
have a bowl of M M's and ten of them are
poison take a handful not all bad apples
hold on a second Tim that's that's
ridiculous first and foremost M M's are
all bad they're sugary they'll kill you
yeah what do you think Lauren you think
that there's some value to this uh the
media narrative at the moment well I
think you're in a situation where you
obviously had had you had a situation
where people wanted to expand the power
of the government where people wanted to
expand the power of the security State
you wanted to see you wanted these
people to be dangerous we've seen the
Fallout from this they've been purging
the military of people who have any kind
of connection to Trump any kind of
support any any you know if you were an
NRA member you could be on a watch list
if you were in the military uh because
of this and possibly up for being
removed so I think there this is part of
a larger interest by kind of those in
power to make sure that you have the
apparatus that is able to crack down on
people and we hear this all the time
from the media right the the biggest
national security threat is you know the
the white supremacists what you the
these radicals you know the these crazy
Q Anon people this is constantly being
pushed for a reason because it allows
you to kind of take that war on terror
apparatus and shift it domestically and
I think that you know this isn't I don't
think that that's this is the only part
of it but I think that that leads into
that narrative for a reason but you know
that the response from many Democrat
activist types is just they're
flabbergasted how is it that fascists
are getting away with all of this
because even when it's proven in a court
of law to not be true they just say it
is so I feel like regardless of whether
or not the state is is empowered by this
they got what they wanted
hard hardcore hyper hyper polarization
in this country the Democrat activists
are still going to continue to be
radicalized by these fake news stories
the the acquittals in the January 6 case
and here do nothing to change that well
when you control the you know consensus
making apparatus there's no reason to
back off the story right if you continue
to push it it doesn't matter what the
facts were at the end of the day you
control the flow of information and if
you can continue to blast that out then
you know someone who really wants to dig
into it can eventually find it but the
vast majority people aren't going to do
that and so the The Narrative that is
you know sitting in people's minds is
that this went down everything you know
went down the way it was originally
portrayed no one goes back and looks at
these things you know years after the
fact to figure out if that was actually
the case and they end up taking the win
I was just watching a bunch of uh
documentary on the rise of the Nazi
party in 1933 Hitler Point appointing of
gerbils to be the propaganda and what
was he the enlightenment minister or
some crazy title and they just They
seized radio they they took control of
it they shut down over slowly over time
first the book burning which is in the
schools the the professors were like hey
kids don't wait for the the government
to to make this policy just go out there
and destroy the knowledge now the
non-german stuff so the kids were all
like yay we think we're doing something
good and then when they got to hold the
radio man talk about manipulation they
shut down the other channels uh you
couldn't get anything out in Germany if
it wasn't State propaganda control of
information but but uh the issue is even
with
the internet grants you the ability to
manipulate but also for the opportunity
for truth like people watching this show
right now I think the difference between
the people who watch this show versus
the people who watch Young Turks is that
for Tim cast IRL listeners new
information will change their mind for
The Young Turks viewers new information
must be fake news and they'll completely
ignore it so like this story like
January 6 they just act like the
Revelation didn't happen at all and so
it almost feels like
the media narrative is is irrelevant at
this point you know they could say
anything and these people would just be
like we don't care we'll do whatever you
say no matter what the story is that's
called Mass formation psychosis I think
I guess I guess yeah we call it mass for
cognitive dissonance there's different
ways to describe the mental cult failure
or yeah I love I love these there's
there's a comic someone posted on
Facebook and it's a woman reading a
newspaper and it says you know Russia
claims there's no Invasion and she's
like how could people fall for this
Russian propaganda and then there's a
guy in a Maga hat with Q on his shirt
watching Tucker Carlson screaming about
a bunch of straw man narratives from the
left and I just thought it was so funny
I'm like this comic is irony it said U.S
bioweapons Labs was one of the things
and I was like that's not the argument
the argument is biological research labs
they the left made that up and then got
mad about it and so that comic to me was
particularly hilarious because they're
mocking the right for being
indoctrinated but the comic itself was
indoctrinating them
it's just it was just pure irony because
those arguments were all strong and
arguments they weren't real arguments
coming from the right so I love it when
they say you know it was um um
Scarborough was he he was referring to I
can't remember I can't remember exactly
what he's talking about but he called
the right occult and it's just like it's
fascinating to me there's an argument
over Trump versus DeSantis who would be
the best person to lead in 2024 but on
the left they're willing to vote for Joe
Biden and mass even though they know
it's going to destroy everything and
they're and they completely ignore
breaking news facts and they're wrong on
every story I mean just go down the list
I think Donald uh who someone tweeted I
should pull up the Instagram image
somebody was pointing out every major
story Russia gate hoax Covington Jesse
Smollett Kyle Rittenhouse
um now the add two more to the mix the
January 6th story we got an acquittal
it's not trespassing the cops let him in
oh get ready for this wave of of
narrative implosion now the Whitmer
story two people not guilty and Strauss
the whole thing Hunter Biden laptop I'm
sorry man when they just believe things
that are repeatedly debunked their
occult
I completely agree yeah I can tell and
this looks very much like a religion to
me I was raised in a religious
environment and while I don't think that
that was in any way a cult you can
definitely see some of the overtones you
have your priests you have your acolytes
you have unforgivable sins you have
original sin sorry which is obviously in
our instance would be like being white
being male all of this other stuff that
you can't change and I would say
definitely this extends to women as well
because if you are not fully feminist
you are a sinner you're cast out and if
you're like Candace Owens you're cast
out as well it doesn't matter what shade
you are the only thing that matters is
connection to this ideology and complete
unquestioning devotion I've got a
definition of cult uh this is from
Wikipedia it was a so or this is from
what is this from Wikipedia I think
social group with
socially deviant or novel religious
philosophical or spiritual beliefs and
practices so deviant or novel meaning
new so the word cult can be doesn't have
to be negative it's a new idea it can be
a new philosophy that a bunch of people
are rallied around colloquially it
refers to a group of people who will not
have their minds Changed by facts and
adhere to a group structure regardless
of reality well I don't think this is a
particularly weird thing I think this is
actually very normal right like your
vast majority of societies throughout
history have been mediated by some kind
of value structure right you have to
have a coherent cultural understanding
of like who you are as a people and what
your values are and so you have to have
something by which not only people judge
their lives and the value of their lives
but also the ways in which they defeat
their enemies and climb in social
standing so this stuff your Devotion to
this stuff is yes it is a a way to find
meaning but it's also a way to obtain
social status which is why it's so
important to Signal your constant
agreement with the current thing right
because if you're not that person the
person next to you is and they're going
to climb above you so I think it has a
lot of different different functions and
I I don't think it's anything
particularly unique throughout history
we're just seeing it because it because
it doesn't have an explicitly religious
nature because it doesn't have an
explicit holy book or someone at the top
who's the Pope we don't treat it the
same way but it has pretty much the same
function I wanna I wanna show you guys I
think what one of the most infuriating
but greatest examples of the failures of
the modern media and the left and it's
this clip that's mythicist myth-informed
Milwaukee guys posted they said uh this
is from a couple days ago Dennis Prager
is mocked on Bill Maher when he
describes the now mainstream leftist
belief that men can menstruate this is
from November 2019. queer Theory and
critical race Theory ideology are so
radical and coherent one risks looking
crazy pointing them out I want to play
this uh
let me let me get the audio fixed I
always do that I always have the audio
set to the wrong setting but let me get
this uh audio properly and then Wing
live we're talking about degrees to say
that men can menstruate is a lie and
that is now that is what is said
okay check it out folks check it out
menstruate what's considered transphobic
I I miss this whole story
where are you getting just Google it
commend menstrual who is saying this
you're talking about you're talking
about a very small percent of people who
are actually powerful mainstream
corporate sources like The Daily Beast
that said July 12 2017 yes men can have
periods and we need to talk about them I
know this is an old story but it's
coming up now with all of the parental
rights and education bills and the fact
that this narrative has become so
prominent this this article was
originally published September 21st 2016
teen three years after a major corporate
publication that was once part I believe
of Newsweek published this ridiculous
story
Bill Maher three years later still
didn't get the memo his audience laughs
these people do not listen to politics
they have no idea what's going on in
this country they don't read the news
but they all think they're smarter than
you that they all bust out laughing it
is just like the story I think it was
Kierkegaard the clown comes on stage and
he says there's a fire backstage
everyone run and the old audience bursts
up laughing thinking it's a joke and so
it becomes even more frantic and they
laugh even harder and he said I think
that's how the world will end yeah
seeing this the reason why I want to
highlight this
is because if back then people like Bill
Maher or Jon Stewart who had been on
Hiatus I suppose had actually paid
attention like people like Dennis Prager
were maybe they wouldn't be dealing with
the insanity they're dealing with now
with the Democrats fleeing the
Democratic party 4-1 in Pennsylvania the
Congressional uh the generic
Congressional ballot being three almost
four points up for republicans and the
rest of us wouldn't have to well you
know I'll just put it this way they
they've done it to themselves you reap
what you sow at this point where I am is
there are two distinct moral universes
and theirs has nothing to do with me
because this is a perfect example of
when they gave up Bill Maher here's what
I tweeted has become lazy and it's sad
Jon Stewart as well it's crazy to me
that they don't do cursory research on
topics anymore Jon Stewart just
absolutely pathetic not a single Google
search oh you can't do that yeah no this
is something that we see very often I
remember back when I first started
making cartoons on the internet and 20
2016 and when I was sort of in a sphere
of people who were criticizing the left
and the far left the criticism we often
received is that we were just talking
about a small niche of leftists who
basically only existed on college
campuses and were completely out of
their minds but these weren't ideas that
it really made much sense to critique
because they were never going to enter
the mainstream and we were more or less
wasting our time now that's obviously
been proven to be completely false these
very Niche bizarre ideas end up becoming
mainstream very quickly and part of the
reason for that is because the left
always needs to find a new cause it's
not as if they move the social dial and
go all right we're done we're satisfied
we've achieved equality now we're going
to let you know we're going to rest and
have society exist as it is they
constantly need to push for more and
more and more yeah I think that also the
the poisoning of our our food supply and
water supply with like microplastics and
birth control that it's being peed into
the sewer systems like is causing people
to go towards this transgender state of
being and so it's that also is adding on
to the to the rhetoric I think that's a
myth I think that's greatly over
exaggerating
we did talk about it I think uh social
manipulation ideological manipulation I
think the fact that you have some people
who are
the epitome of follower and they'll just
go along with whatever I mean how many
people watch that episode of Bill Maher
and laughed along with them thinking he
was the smart one in the room when he
was just dead wrong and they follow
along with that for years and now these
stories that were published in the
corporate press six seven years ago are
now in the Forefront at our schools now
these are the parents these liberal
parents in Loudoun County who are now
freaking out and voting Republican these
Suburban moms who are starting to wake
up and freak out because they watch
shows like that so I think
indoctrination manipulation but pure
laziness from Bad leaders I'll say it in
a little bit of Defense of Bill Maher I
have a lot of criticism Bill Maher but
he uh Prager came at him and kind of
Blindsided with that data and neither of
them knew could back it up like um Bill
asked him can where'd you get that data
who said that and Dennis didn't have an
answer he didn't say The Daily Beast he
should have quoted the article if he's
going to bring it up
um
so I suppose I suppose the issue I had
was uh with with Dennis is that he was
heated when he said it if he presented
in a more calm demeanor it wouldn't have
elicited the same response well
sorry I don't mean to interrupt you no
no I was just going to say but yeah I
did a tweet on this and and it's very
clear that this pattern right we see
this all the time it starts with oh no
this isn't happening it's not a real
thing and then it goes to well maybe
it's here and there it's a few crazies
and then by the end of it oh well it's
good actually right and this is the most
predictable thing you can imagine three
years ago this was a right-wing
conspiracy now it's something that every
major corporation every major
educational institution and now even the
government is saying this is the most
predictable thing in the world and the
amazing thing about this is that Bill
Maher this will not change his priors at
all he will not think for a moment I was
wrong he did this interview with I think
it was Ben Shapiro recently and he said
you know it's not me you know the the I
didn't change the left change it never
occurs to him for a moment that there is
a reason that people keep getting left
behind by the left there is a reason
that this keeps occurring it's a pattern
it's predictable I've had I've had
people ask me to you know reach out or
people who are connected did you know
saying like would you want to get in
touch with the people at Bill Maher I
don't want to say too much about it
because it's not going to happen and I
wonder if I should try and extend an
olive branch in some capacity to talk to
the guy because he has said some good
things about how woke the left has
become but I'd be directly critical of
so much you know there was the uh Ben
Shapiro Malcolm Nance conversation yeah
and that was fantastic and Ben is
correct I don't care about your opinions
on policy I care about if you're talking
about facts and when a conservative
comes out and says here's a thing that
is true and here's evidence I say okay
that's true then they say here's my
opinion on the policy I say well that we
can discuss what's happening now is a
conservative like Ben Shapiro goes on
daily goes on a uh uh Real Time with
Bill Maher and says here are the facts
and they go oh whoa whoa whoa whoa and
it's like if you haven't done the
research Bill how are you hosting this
show so so Ian I I I accept your point
especially about Dennis Prager being
unable to say here's where it's
happening I think the issue for Dennis
was it was three years beyond the point
of this this conversation beginning so
the answer was actually every major
corporate website corporate news upset
has stated this in some form or another
he pulled an Ian Crossland Dennis Prager
did he he did a derail the conversation
and then didn't know what he was talking
about couldn't back it up and everyone
thought he was an idiot but he was right
but here's what we do and this is why
I'm gonna say it right now look I think
Bill Maher's show is just it's it's just
okay archaic it's obsolete yeah on this
show if someone comes on the show and
says it's a lie to say that you know men
can menstruate you know we do pull it
out we all have laptops that's right and
and the desktop terminal let's let's
search in real time it's remarkable to
me that Bill Maher still exists in this
vacuum is the show's called real time
it's called real time can't take his
phone and I mean even Dennis couldn't
pull out his phone and be like there you
go here let's search in real time though
do you guys even read the news and you
know what I would have said when they
all started laughing I take my phone up
I'd pull it up and I'd say there it is
guys 2016 The Daily Beast want me to get
another article you made tell me I'm the
only one on this panel who actually
reads the news then why do any of you
think you should have an opinion on news
yeah and also not to Monday Morning
Quarterback Prager here too much but I
would have asked her I like to think I
would have asked why is that wrong why
is what I'm saying incorrect do you not
believe that men can become women
because this was a mainstream view on
the left and if that's the case then why
isn't it the case that men can menstrual
when Dennis Prager goes on to say that
college dorms for for males have tampons
uh Bill Marshals that's for their
girlfriends talk about
you take a guy like Bill Maher you know
what I think I think he retired this is
I think we see a lot of this I think
Bill Maher retired in his mind yeah
mentally yeah yeah like he's like look
I've been doing this for decades I'm so
exhausted there's other things I want to
do I'm not going to read the news all
day just give me the give me the copy
I'll read it and we'll talk about
whatever Politically Incorrect was
badass and then he got after 9 11 it was
like some government clamp down there
like he's saying too much shut him down
and they shut his show down and I think
he changed after that he was like whoa I
got a self-censor now or I'm gonna not
make it
well they put him on HBO and the idea
was that he didn't have to worry about
it and I used to watch this all the time
I used to watch Daily Show all the time
and I will point this out every time Jon
Stewart praised project Veritas on more
than one occasion that's great now he's
just woke yelling at Andrew Sullivan and
it's just
all of this stuff is the lowest of low
brow garbage my the reason I bring it up
here is because Dennis Prager was
correct on this prageru has been leading
the charge granted conservative ideology
I don't care they're correct when they
say the left has made the argument now
they give their counter argument you can
agree with them or disagree with them
but their premise is correct and people
like Bill Maher people like Jon Stewart
people like Stephen Colbert have
abandoned what they once were supposedly
representing which was reality yeah like
Colbert said right reality has a liberal
bias now it's fictional cult world has a
liberal bias and the rest of us are
confused as to what these people are
reading when they read anything if they
read anything and that's a really
important point one thing you mentioned
earlier is the fact that societies and
cultures have always had Authority
structures and they've always had rules
that people are expected to follow but
part of what's so bizarre about this is
you basically have rules which are
wildly unpopular and historically
unprecedented that the left is forcing
on everyone else and it is even most
people on the left it's a very small
percentage of extra extremely online
individuals who will complain to
corporations and make them feel as if
they need to censor themselves and
change their corporate structuring and
web advertising why what's wrong because
it's around 10 of the of the population
well it's increasing it it is absolutely
increasing and I think the idea is
spread but chances are when you
encounter someone who says a man can
become a Woman They Don't genuinely
believe that I'm not saying that
absolves them from saying it it's
actually an even bigger problem because
they are being dishonest but most people
recognize this stuff as ridiculous the
question is how do we make them feel
comfortable saying that when I was
talking to a friend of mine on Facebook
and I told the story before and she all
of a sudden started adopting the gender
ideology stance
she she told me you know the whole uh
she was like trans women or women trans
men or men and I said okay I don't care
if that's your your premise my question
to you then is I asked her you would be
physically attracted to someone who's
biologically female like a person with a
vagina but who is like you know got a
beard and and she was like I could learn
how to do that and I was like that
sounds like conversion therapy to me and
she just blocked me yeah because like
it's it's because there is I I feel like
a lot of these people are not strong
moral leaders not everybody is I feel
like many of these people just want to
be followers because it's simpler and
the logic of their brains is conflicted
with the survival aspect of their brain
to fit in with Society I must just say
this yeah exactly well and that's that's
extremely Insidious because ultimately
you either live what you believe or
believe what you live as they say and if
you stay silent about the truth for long
enough you do start to believe the lie
so I'm not saying that we're not at risk
of people buying into this we very
clearly are and my view is the exact
opposite we are in danger but oftentimes
conservatives are trying to convince
people on these issues what we need to
be doing is help people understand that
the thing that they already actually
secretly believe is not something that
they should be embarrassed or afraid to
say but here's the thing and you got to
remember this societies are run by
organized minorities every time so
saying that it's not everybody on the
left of course it's not yeah that's not
what matters what matters is who on the
left believes it and where they sit in
positions of power there's a reason
everyone is adopting this stuff it's not
because they necessarily believe it
right away but eventually they do
believe it I think they do eventually
genuinely take it on board because they
understand this received morality is
advantageous in our society they know
that and so that's why people will do
like Tim was talking about they will go
out and they will alter their beliefs
system because the people who are
important are telling them what is going
to come next what is going to be
signaled as positive what is going to
increase their standing and what's going
to make it easier for them to get along
along with what's actually going to be
moral and so saying oh just a few people
believe in or it's a small already if
it's the right minority that's the most
dangerous thing possible I wouldn't
disagree with any of that but what I
would reaffirm is my point that what we
have to do in order to combat that is
have people speak their minds and speak
the truth because it's only going to be
powerful if we acquiesce to it
I got this quote here uh Darwin it's not
the strongest of the species that
survives nor the most intelligent is
that how it goes but it's the one that
is most adaptable to change uh
terrifying but true well have you guys
ever seen Idiocracy yep Mike Judge man
talk about brilliant I love the point
made in the beginning eventually
Evolution wasn't rewarding the strongest
or the smartest it was rewarding those
who simply reproduced the most
yeah as as a species we have created
this sphere of safety where we're
untouched from War in the United States
for the most part in the past what 200
years or 150 years or so Civil War
obviously was bad uh we're on we we do
have crime but relative to the rest of
the world we have fat homeless people I
mean a serious problem in this country
and though we do have poverty we are
extremely wealthy uh extremely wealthy
extremely well fed extremely safe and so
this has created that environment that
Mike Judge was sort of talking about
Evolution simply rewarding those who
reproduce the most but in this case it's
ideological reproduction exactly yeah I
mean it's just the ideas that become the
most popular that end up governing your
Society now I'm very optimistic in some
sense I believe that ultimately in the
final final analysis the truth wins but
your Society has no guarantee of
existing forever in in a more like
darwinist
previous iteration of our civilization
less technologically advanced the
strongest and the smartest would survive
by by nature of their ideology working
together having strong families having
strong communities being armed now
everything's so safe the ideology has
become becoming more powerful and
dominant is deconstructivists is
reductivist it's a blank slate it is
it's deconstruction yes it's breaking
everything apart now that can exist
because we're in such a magnificent
bubble of wealth and security until they
destroy it by deconstructing it and then
it's going to be just pure chaos man
like you know the food shortages that
are coming yes the the product of
electing someone like Joe Biden out of
sheer ignorance resulting in the chaos
that we've had over the past year I am
developing the probably highly unpopular
opinion and you're welcome to pitch in
on this if you think along the same
lines that we desperately need some form
of hardship to make us realize that our
imagined difficulties are just that
they're completely imaginary we have
much bigger things to worry about we've
just never had to worry or even think
about our survival we don't know where
our food comes from that's a huge
problem we're about to learn that's
troubling I think it's what we need
that's the amazing thing too like I
visited farms and growing up in the city
it really was a aha moment when I saw
actual production right because I mean
Illinois's got Farms you know but people
don't even can connect the dots of the
the wheat Fields get you know harvested
and then sent to processing and then it
makes its way to a factory and it gets
turned into food the first time I
watched How It's Made and they were like
cupcakes how they're made and it shows
like a guy pouring huge a massive bag of
fly to this giant fat and I'm just like
wow and then the machine like cranking
out the cupcakes and sealing the bags
how it's made at this amazing show how
it's made is an amazing show because
people don't don't recognize supply
chain you go to the store boom cupcakes
in a wrapper you got no idea how they
got there you grew there yep just blink
there it is it's interesting if you went
to the store and on every piece of food
you were gonna buy there was a little
video under it that was showing you the
entire manufacturing process of the
piece starting oh no bro no so uh
Machiavelli talked about ruling rule of
foxes and rules rule of lions right and
your foxes are your very clever
quick-witted they're going to be kind of
your liberals they're going to be the
people who are good at combining and
coming up with new ideas and then your
lions are going to be kind of your more
conservative patriotic martial type
people and he said at the beginning your
civilizations are always run by lions
because they have to secure safety you
have to make sure you're getting food
supply those kind of things but over
time as your Society gets more complex
you start to see the rise of the foxes
because they're able to address these
new things these new problems that are
coming up they're able to make these new
combinations and synthesize things but
as your Society gets more decadent as
you get further away from the problems
that the Lions solve you forget why you
had lines in the first place and your
foxes become the dominant rule in class
and we are so far around the bend we are
all foxes right everyone in charge right
now is a college grad they've never been
in the military they've never farmed
they don't know anything about this
stuff food shows up at their table truck
drivers bring it to them they never give
it a second thought of course the world
say for America we can conquer anything
and so they don't think about what
happens when you can no longer just work
your way out of this by being clever
what happens when the rubber meets the
road and you know what lions do
line sleep
they sleep most of the day lionesses I
guess what might actually do work but
the male lions just
just sleep and it kind of feels like
that's what it is the foxes have started
conniving started scheming and taking
things while the lion looks around and
he's like
hey Simba all the sun touches is ours
yeah I'm going to bed yep and then the
foxes run in and just start controlling
everything and the lines don't pay
attention they sleep to conserve their
energy for the hunt or something no they
just they just sleep the lionesses do
the hunting yeah yeah the dudes
basically get up eat bang and go to
sleep so Kamala Harris she's the Lioness
and this is crazy I don't know she's
probably the hyena yeah
if we're doing Lion King she's
definitely yeah
is it too far gone
the I think the system's gonna have to
go through them through some serious
hard times and probably a little bit of
collapse before people realize the issue
I I think that we've been trained to
believe that experts are the key right
you gotta have an expert for everything
you need to have a person who has a
particular degree and has enough
doctorates enough credentials and
they're the ones that solve everything
everything is solvable through like this
kind of managerial scientific you know
system
but it's not and at the end of the day
you there are certain things that have
to be done physically in the real world
it's not just always ideas that solve
these problems and I think until people
taste some of the difficulty that comes
from a society that's entirely based on
kind of fox Governors they're they're
never going to realize the problem
perhaps but it's also possible that we
can succeed in all of this by doing
literally nothing why well as I
mentioned They are tearing everything
down and the strong are the ones who are
going to figure things out and survive
the left likes to make fun of the fact
that we promote emergency food but in
the event you actually need it it's not
even not even going to be us that's
laughing it's going to be the Preppers
in the mountains with the 30 years worth
of beans calling us amateurs but they
can live in their cities with no food
supply no understanding of it as
everything falls apart but maybe there's
we just have to do very little but
remain resilient we have the story from
Daily Mail breaking Discovery completes
its merger with Warner media and
acquires the rights for CNN HBO and
Warner browse content as staff fear
bloodbath of layoffs uh well okay well
well all right yeah let's uh should we
get the cake now or should we wait until
they start laying people off because CNN
plus also guys can I just make an
announcement here
so CNN plus launched on day one they cut
their price subscription in half yep a
day later there was reporting that CNN
was expecting layoffs because the sign
ups were so abysmal now I don't know how
many signups they got I don't know how
much money they made I assume it was bad
I just want to say in one month chicken
city has 21
000 subscribers
and today we had six chicken parties
we are on track for year one of chicken
City to make 100 000 plus dollars those
are golden chickens and as I stated a
man who watches chicken city is more
more informed and better informed than a
man who watches CNN correct now I'm half
kidding like it is funny to mention that
our chicken live stream is doing so well
there's a real value to it and that
people are putting their their pets in
front of it people like super chatting
and they they use chicken city as a chat
room basically throughout the day to
talk about a lot of ideas from this show
even but I I I I ultimately just want to
get to the point where
CNN is crumbling these networks are
failing their ratings are in the gutter
our ratings are improving every day look
at the daily wire these guys are making
over a hundred million dollars per year
now it's just it's an explosion
and we're looking at sentiment when the
left these activists try saying things
like the right is the Republican is
minority rule it's just you know what
moderate voters side with Republicans on
most issues two to one right now you
look at all of the data you look at
black lives matter you look at the
Democrats look at the economy you look
at inflation you look at gas it's all
like 60 percent Independents are you
know on the same side as Republicans and
they think they're the majority yeah
they're they're spiraling out of control
their companies are crumbling and we
only need keep steering our ship
focusing on building and developing
cultural content media content websites
and I think we're going to be I think
we'll be all right no I think you're
absolutely correct I've brought this uh
stat up on the show before but more
Americans would rather we look into the
2020 BLM rights and investigate those
then support the January 6th commission
it's because a bunch of buildings got
destroyed in that thing yeah how about
that how about that a lot of people got
killed how about when the Republicans
take over in November we launched the
BLM committee the BLM investigatory
committee they should I'm open man but I
am so done with the witch hunts I do not
think that is the way forward wrong
they're gonna cast a spell on you Ian
wrong must we burn the witches Sheamus
wrong Ian
when they come out and and Levy a whole
bunch of fake investigations and put
Kyle Rittenhouse through the ringer for
for two years basically or a year
solitary when they put the j6 defendants
through the solitary confinement
effectively torturing them and now we're
saying oh what's that acquittals suicide
look some people rioted they're gonna go
to jail for that that's that I
understand and they should many of these
people were bumbling around confused and
they lock them up for how long they
rated a woman I think it was in Alaska
she was the wrong person
so then all of a sudden the Republicans
take over and Ian people like you say
it's time to end the witch hunts and the
Democrats go good good good because when
you ask for free uh when I ask for
Freedom uh you give it to me because
it's according to your principles but uh
what what what's the saying actually
it's like when Frank Herbert yeah yeah
what's the what's the question when you
were when you were when you were strong
I asked for freedom because it was
according to your principles uh now that
I am strong I deny it to you deny you
because that's according to my
principles and so the problem with the
liberty-minded individuals civil
Libertarians Libertarians conservatives
is they keep doing this and they've kept
doing this
Joe Biden should be impeached day one
for his illicit dealings in Ukraine but
I am willing to bet Republicans like
Mitch McConnell is going to step up and
say no we don't want to do that what
would Jesus do
what did he say about buying a sword oh
yeah he does not have uh uh sword
sellers cloak and buy one yes I I think
I think it'd be fair to say that um
you're supposed to protect yourself from
people who would wrong you and try to
destroy you you right Jesus went into
the temple and he flipped tables because
those money changers were cheating
people I think the Bible wrote him to be
way more passive than he actually was
because he did toss tables around an
attempt but everything you know about
him is from the Bible and what's written
there so well I don't want to make this
a religious discussion okay but I'm
trying to think of the it's political
you know the the um you can't be like
now that I have power I will let all of
you be free after your illegal illegal
dealings your manipulations your scams
and your criminal Behavior you're all
forgiven one problem they get elected
they come and they lock you up if you
did like a a tribunal that was like an
independent tribunal that wasn't a
governmental thing it was I don't know
how you could actually do an independent
thing this day and age but you got to
make sure that it's not left to its own
devices because it will just continue to
do what it does which is root people out
so you got to watch out for like
McCarthyism all over again
well yeah I don't know I think I think
just because you can point and this is
sort of the problem with the Witch Hunt
analogy it just because you can point to
examples in the past that you feel were
a group of people being overzeal in
their attempt to clean their society up
that doesn't mean that bad people
shouldn't be held accountable when they
do bad things and that we shouldn't have
trials to figure out who's destroying
our culture
Society yeah the problem is that the
right things it's having a discussion on
the left knows it's fighting War they
know this is the ratchet the the right
things that they're adhering to a set of
principles they think that they're the
ones going by the Constitution playing
Fair we want to be objective we want to
follow the rules the left knows they're
fighting for control of the culture
politics is about rewarding your friends
and punishing your enemies and we can
all sit around and pretend like we've
been beyond that we're better people
than that the end of this then at the
end of the day that's what works that's
what maintains power and that's how you
win and that's how you make things
better if you're the ones who are going
to make things better and we we don't
like that because it feels icky it feels
uh restrictive but but it's true and you
we can cry about all we want or we can
realize the truth that's been in front
of us for many many years and what plays
out every day we see it all the time and
it's not even as if we're just going
these people are our enemies and we only
want to punish them because we disagree
with them they were they were burning
down buildings people got killed they
destroyed businesses people were
terrified it's incredible how quickly
people forgot what the summer of 2020
was yeah one of the things that I
noticed actually today was that you need
to strive to be the better person in
your personal life but when it comes to
politics you have to be pragmatic
because the conservatives have attempted
to apply political or personal Dynamics
to politics they want to be friendly
they want to be the better person they
don't want to do to katanji Brown
Jackson what they did to Brett Kavanaugh
but they are losing and that's why the
groomers is working but look at the
media narrative on katanji Brown Jackson
the president gets up and says can you
believe what those Republicans did and
all these Democrats are like they
besmirched her good name it's like you
accused Brett Kavanaugh of being party
to gang rape well yeah exactly and this
is the difference and they asked her
about her her actual record right yes
and so that's my exact point people
compare the right and the left and
anytime the right actually shows its
teeth or tries to do anything effective
people go oh they're just as bad as the
left ignoring the fact that we are using
actual facts and events that happen to
talk about this person's record and not
smearing someone without any evidence
which is what they did to Kavanaugh and
to the point about groomers that it's
not as if that's the wrong terminology
to refer to the people who are opposing
this bill once they know it's about
preventing adults from having secret
conversations about sex with children
that they tell them not to repeat to
their parents I think so it's not like
the right is going out there saying
we're going to use these you know
illicit or dirty techniques to go after
the left the way they they do to us it's
the right is saying let's be reasonable
and hold people accountable for doing
bad things and then the response from we
conservatives is that makes us just as
bad as them we need to excise this is
what my medicine we need to start
building our own systems
gaining control of of platforms that we
like Elon Musk buying Twitter brilliant
daily wire launching their own uh
children's content movies and streaming
platform kind of stuff brilliant when
when when you're on the playground at
recess and the and and the bully kids or
whatever are demanding that you say or
believe something you don't believe
otherwise you're not cool be like I'm
gonna go over the side of the playground
I'm gonna make my own game and you guys
can't can't play it and then do
something cool and fun and convince
people to join you instead of engaging
with people who are cheating the whole
time I always tell people this
we're all playing a game of Monopoly
they're overtly cheating every time
and then we just sit there and and for
the longest time the right uh and and I
think now it's helping the right is the
is the post-liberals joining The Fray
giving them a larger uh a larger uh
amount of forces in the culture War but
for the longest time we're just like I
know they're cheating but if I just play
harder I'll win and it's not even that
it's not even like they're cheating and
the right is saying well well we want to
follow the rules it's like they're
cheating and then they land on Boardwalk
which we own and there's hotels on it we
go it would be too mean to make them pay
the amount that the game says that they
should yeah you owe me a thousand but
that would bankrupt you so yeah we're
gonna be really nice can you imagine if
you played Monopoly like that um I think
technically you don't have to take rent
if they land on your property I'm not
sure about that well you don't because
you're allowed to do free trade um this
I kind of see this metaphor as if
there's a brain worm infested in the
American mind and the left arm is
flailing around smacking itself and the
right arm's like whoa that arm's out of
control cutting off the arm is not it
might work but it's not the solution
it's just like a Band-Aid you know dude
haven't you seen Idle Hands with Seth
Green no the solution was to Lop the
handoff man his hand got possessed by
the devil or whatever Tails from the
Crypt yeah that that just doesn't feel
right though to like go after the people
when it's this like weird banking
mentality thing that sees to control the
government when you go on a dangerous
hike through cold weather
and your left hand is frostbitten and
rotted and then you you when you go back
into the warmth and it starts thawing
the dead particles can toxify your
system no snap you've got to cut it off
yeah you do you've got to remove it it
has it gone necrotic I would I would say
yes dude look at what's going on right
now you know I just tweeted would
Progressive parents give their minor
Sons breast implants if they were trans
because breast implants are temporary
can be removed but mastectomies are
permanent because they are giving minor
girls mastectomies
and that's a shocking question I suppose
when we get to the point where where
we're talking about to what degree are
we willing to provide surgeries to
children to make them feel better like
the systems and you know what who was it
who was it who said that um
uh cultures that are obsessed with
gender on the verge of collapsing like
that have you heard that
because we we've seen it in many
different civilizations
the obsession over gender completely
ignores the realities of every other
mental uh you know dysmorphic issue
like the only one that matters to the
left into the mainstream media is gender
even though there's many other uh body
dysmorphia issues like weight like
anorexia or um what what is bot what is
it like General body dysmorphic disorder
where you want to like cut your hands
off and stuff like that yeah yeah a
trans ableism I think that's something
that's what that's called when you feel
like you're in the wrong body so you cut
a piece off and then it's it's called
like General dysmorphic disorder it was
Jordan Peterson that has been talking
about this he was on Rogan talking about
it episode 1769. actually Ian it was me
on Rogan in 2018 talking about it
technically it goes back to Aristotle
when he first um no but but this is
exactly what I said to Dorsey I was like
are you going to create protections for
people who want to remove their hands or
ears or nose or something I think that's
ridiculous that's too far to me man when
you start surgically cutting yourself
off like that's too much you're doing it
already yeah geez girls under the age of
18 are already getting permanent Top
surgery to their chests now
I suppose it's up to the parents or
whatever but I kind of feel like when
you're an adult and you're you're you
know we've crossed a certain threshold
where we're like that's where you're old
enough you make decisions for your life
to do body modification when we're at
the point where there was a study I
tweeted about earlier 13 to 25 year olds
uh females were surveyed on uh half of
them got mastectomies half of them
didn't the median age for the mastectomy
was 19 but it included it was it was
overwhelmingly 14 and 15 year olds
that's child abuse who are having their
their breasts removed now the reason I
asked this is you can give a male breast
implants and that's temporary meaning at
some point if something happens they can
be removed and all is you know
relatively back to normal but for for
young women the mastectomies are
permanent I I don't want to get into all
of that stuff actually we have a story
we can talk about in that regard but I
bring this up when you when you're
saying it has it gone necrotic and I'm
like
the point I bring up with that
how is it that that's a question to be
asked of the left based on their own
ideology with their children should 14
year old boys get breast implants I'm
asking that because they are already
surgically removing the breasts of girls
yeah exactly so once we've gotten to the
point where the left would say that you
know giving a mastectomy to a minor
should be legal and isn't child abuse
you're not dealing with an arm that
isn't working I think it's more akin to
a tumor and the problem is that when it
comes on the internet and other kids see
it on Tick Tock and they're like oh I
want to be accepted so I'll do what that
guy's doing cutting himself up that's
when it becomes necrotic that's when you
get blood poisoning and sepsis is when
it's in the system infecting the system
I think uh you know typically I say I
defer to the doctors of you know many of
these these kids and these families I
genuinely believe that there are issues
of depression and and dysphoria and all
that stuff and and they need to find a
way to deal with this in Scandinavian
countries that the left uh often likes
to tout in terms of their medical care
they do uh Psychotherapy and they do uh
they're like um like uh you know
sessions they don't they don't
immediately go for pharmaceuticals or
surgery
so if we were to look to the
Scandinavian countries which are
bastions of great Medical Services you'd
see there's there's less of of this you
know lots of these circumstances
occurring and maybe that's the right way
to do it maybe you know what I I gotta
say I'm in favor of those those
socialist Scandinavians right yeah not
really socialists but you get my point
oh yeah I hear you I'm not trying to get
get into a conversation about trans I'm
trying to point out that there is a
fractured logic
in what's happening there's no
conversation about body dysmorphia
there's no conversation about people who
have who are cutting cutting their ears
cutting their fingers off and things
like that because those people exist as
well and they're also in very small
proportions there's no conversation
about protecting trans-racial people in
fact transracial people are shunned and
and mocked for instance people like um
and uh is Sean King transracial or is he
just what's his deal pretending I think
I don't know well he says he's biracial
right I don't know though because like I
I don't know the story I slept around I
think was the issue oh is that what it
was yeah oh so he actually does I don't
know he identifies this biracial I guess
I mean he's wider than Rachel dolezal
yeah he's pretty he is yeah
pretty bad so I you know I don't know
the at this point you know
he's he's still considered I guess a lot
of people hate him you know to be honest
yeah uh bipartisanly people hate him
they think it's yeah but he's still
prominent yeah yeah he's still prominent
and so if we're at the point now where
someone who at the very least looks
overtly white can give themselves a
haircut and put up a sepia tone
photograph and they're considered black
it just feels like there's no cultural
cohesion so yeah necrotic the system is
completely broken it makes very little
sense and you've got people right now
the article we read the other day where
the guy said why are Republicans so
concerned about grooming and I'm like
okay yo we got a problem so I just
ignore it I ignore it you can't ignore
sepsis though that's how people die
blood poisoning yep that's right it's a
good point that's right man I think you
were I think you made a very cogent
point that people are are people's
adaptability is overriding their
intellect and their strength and that's
a natural part like that what Darwin was
saying a natural part of the survival
Instinct is you adapt if you have a
totalitarian government and you don't
adapt it kills you so the adaptable
survive but why why you know this is the
the thing you know when I was talking to
this friend of mine this was several
years ago because we're not friends
anymore she she deleted her Facebook she
blocked me wow she blocked me and then
deleted her Facebook and I think it was
because
what I pointed out
that the logic of her mind what she knew
to be true was conflicted with what she
had to say in order to survive but I'm
like why say it to me you know like I
was having a candid conversation where I
wasn't telling her to believe anything I
was asking her questions about what she
believed I had another friend who who uh
was talking to me on Facebook and I sent
them un statistics on the refugee crisis
and I think what I said was what we're
seeing with um the uh I think it's the
central Mediterranean route for refugees
was predominantly economic migrants from
places like Nigeria and the the Eastern
route was refugees from Syria and
Afghanistan and she got really angry and
blocked me and I'm like yo I'm not
messaging my friends and being like
you're so dumb I was like hey how's it
going how you been and then they're
talking like I'm just really upset about
what's going on with the refugee stuff
in these crises and I'm like yeah man I
hear you it's it's brutal stuff and then
they'd say something like all of these
people are just fleeing War I can't
understand why we can't help them and
then I said well I mean the news we're
actually seeing about Italy is actually
the central route here here's an article
from the UN and they're like Fu bad that
sounds like a six-year relationship I
was in I try and bring up logic and
she'd be like yeah you don't understand
me and I'm like okay logic isn't the way
to communicate with everyone sometimes
you need emotion and to listen yeah but
when someone says I'm mad about
something that isn't happening and then
I'm and then I'm like oh well you know
here's the UN is saying yeah and then
they freak out even more the system I
would have she'd be like I'm I'm in pain
I'm having a hard time like well you
know if you did this it would make it
and she'd be like I don't want I just
want you to tell me it's gonna be okay
you know and it's like
that's large it's just it's just the
other half Mars Women Are from Venus
hello if there's a lesson we should
learn from all this it's that the
marketplace of ideas is a fiction it's
not a real thing it's not how societies
change their minds it's not how
individuals change their mind yes of
course we all have rational
conversations and there are situations
where you can bring facts to people and
if they're open to you they're going to
go ahead and change mine but they have
to be pretty close to you already right
you rarely get to a situation where
someone is on the entirely different
Spectrum or you don't have a large
amount of trust built up with them and
you just drop the facts on them and they
say oh okay you're right I'll just go
ahead and concede this thing that
totally alters and shatters my worldview
because you happen to bring me facts
that's not how people work unfortunately
it's again it's it's about making sure
to understand how these things get
communicated how this information gets
manipulated and until people have a
better understanding of how that happens
and people on the right and the post
left are willing to understand that and
utilize that I think they're going to
continue to just kind of fall on their
face trying to have these circular
arguments that never go anywhere I have
a solution
Elon the market cap of Twitter I believe
is around what 50 billion dollars
you have access to that level of capital
now you're going to have to sell a
decent amount of Tesla that could be
dangerous for you I understand but
you're rich
buy 100 of Twitter and then shut it down
completely now first of all I'm joking
right but I'm only half choking the
problem we're facing is that Twitter
keeps people in the cult
to get someone out of a cult you have to
remove them from the cult
expose them to a diversity of World
Views and opinions so they can see that
this one cult worldview isn't correct
but what happens
when you go to someone and say you know
X Plus y equals z as like a fact
statement like here's Hunter Biden was
doing illicit dealings in Ukraine and
based on the evidence of him sharing a
bank account with his dad it seems
likely that Joe Biden was involved in
illicit dealings Joe Biden got the
prosecutor fired we know all these
stories give them that information the
problem is they open their phone right
back up and they get sucked right back
into the cult patting them on the back
hugging them telling them no no they're
the cult we are the right ones we are
the ones who are telling you the truth
like Brian stelter do you guys see that
that high school kid I think it was a
high school kid right it's called
freshman College freshman yeah he he
said he asks Brian like here's all the
stories that you guys have gotten wrong
and Brian goes when that reporter got
seriously injured in Ukraine we all were
there for him because that's what real
news does talk about I call them a
politician yeah you answer the question
that sounds like something Michael Scott
would say right yeah office quote
because they're a cult now of course the
right has their zealots but here's the
funny thing that ain't us Luke ragged on
Trump non-stop Ian Rags on Trump but we
have we try to have real conversations
about this the best of our abilities and
they would call us the cult so when
you've got a cult that genuinely
believes they're right and they're wired
in
how do you get them away from unless you
delete Twitter outright now pondering
upon that imagine how bad it will be in
the metaverse when people are just
plugged in like the board
yeah there's no Escape no I'm staying
away from any kind of hyper reality as
much as possible no no thank you how
embedded are you in your device these
days I mean I can't pretend like yeah I
spend some time on Twitter that's true
but uh uh no just just thinking along
these lines what do we do moving forward
when Twitter has become the The Hive
cult that people are already plugged in
whether you get an implant for it or not
people are wired to the to the net
they're in the Matrix already man
what do you do I gotta have a an
unlimited amount of twitters basically
it's the only way with unlimited amounts
of terms of service because you're never
going to please everyone that's that's
not the issue the issue is these people
are already on Twitter and when you say
here's the truth here's the evidence
they go whoa I didn't realize that then
they pick up their phone and Retreat
back to their safe space it doesn't
matter if it's Twitter or minds or [ __ ]
shoot it's people building communal safe
spaces for confirmation so that was
probably the war you were talking about
it's like a constant erosion of thought
and regrowth of thought
I mean ideally we would all actually
have safer spaces and I know that's not
going to be a popular thing to say but
the the reality is that America is not a
country that's going to build consensus
ever again and we we need to come to
that realization oh we need to
understand that the people who are you
know in California you know going you
know setting this kind of stuff up for
kids and the people who are in deep red
States who are Banning it I think was
Alabama just just Bandit they live
entirely of different lives they
entirely different value systems there
is no overlap anymore it in a lot of
ways there never was we we think of
America as one uh cohesive culture but
really until World War II it wasn't
there wasn't that level of mass
communication to build that kind of
thing there wasn't a level of
standardized education to bind people
together under a certain amount of
experiences everyone's seeing the same
movie everybody's listening the same
music it simply didn't exist and so I
think it's actually really unhealthy for
everyone to be linked together across a
country where people basically like
desperately just agree on all kinds of
value-based issues and we would all be
in a much better situation if people
could go back to being able to have
smaller communities and more Regional
moralities and be able to deal with
their own way unfortunately I don't
think that the government's going to let
people do that but I think that would be
the better solution here's something to
consider too based on what you're saying
you know back in the day our elections
tended to be more more local right
because of the way communication
happened even in the past 20 years local
news outlets that you know you turn on
your channel 5 news or whatever and it's
your town your region you're getting
information based on this area it's
still to this day exists but for the
most part it's dying out now what ends
up happening is someone like
ocasio-cortez stands up and screams her
radicalism and her insane ideas about
farting cows and there's one crazy
person in every city who normally has no
power but when they heed the call on the
internet they now Focus fire their
donations to someone like AOC who is
then able to win her district and get
into federal office this is this is
taking the radical voices that are
normally disparate across the country
unifying them in a digital space
amplifying their power and then creating
serious hyperpolarization in government
and God forbid across the world it's no
longer like a national it's like people
in the China can donate to AOC you know
through whatever means they feel like
they got to go through that and and it's
illegal but they they figure out ways to
do it it's it's it's it's insane people
need to understand this how easy it is
for any country to put money into our
elections China can reach out to Sheamus
and say would you be willing to uh uh uh
animate something for us and we'll pay
you ten thousand dollars and Sheamus
goes oh yeah great you know it's it's
just some Chinese company then he gets
paid 10 grand and then he's got this
money and he goes I'm going to donate to
a politician of course you know in that
circumstance we're talking about the the
the subversive method of they could hire
like Russia does this right Russia was
hiring people who had dissident views to
work for RT and Sputnik someone who has
an anti-establishment or dissonant voice
would be paid and that alone gave them
resources to function and this is in the
United States and allow their ideas to
flourish more
China can do the same thing they can
find a bunch of social justice activists
put money into non-profits the
non-profits will then fund these
activists who then help support these
politicians or if they want to be a bit
more direct they can get an American
citizen who does something illegal and
just takes a contract with them knowing
they want him to give money to
politicians or start super Pacs and I
would imagine corporations could do that
as well
could send the money so it wouldn't have
to be like the corporations do it all
the time bro corporations foreign
corporations 100 oh yeah hundreds of
millions of dollars into into political
action committees and other non-profits
and they can they can they can do all of
these things short of like a complete
Global power outage I don't see any way
to go back like a great reset
unfortunately that would they'd still
have power yeah a great reset with no
power that's a that's another
conversation I don't have the answers
man I can just see bad stuff happening
and so it's I'm so black pilled lately
help me well no no no no hold on hold on
we start by talking about how we need
only steer the ship CNN and all these
networks are sinking but that's bad they
just got bought it's a corporate uh
oligarchy they're laying people off
they're consolidating because they're
falling apart bro
well that might be that might be true
yeah but it's the one Corporation bought
three more who is it who bought who
discovery bought Warner yep they bought
Warner and merger okay just remember how
well the daily wire and Tim cast are
doing
fantastic yeah you can start your own
company too you can whip it up pretty
quick these days that's right we're
looking at these companies crumbling
we're looking at Democrat polls
collapsing Republicans in Pennsylvania
switching a a stealing Democrat voters
four to one so for every for every
Republican who quits to be a Democrat
Republicans get Democrats four to one I
don't know if you guys know it's super
easy to start a corporation like really
really easy you go to like I went to
legalzoom.com and it's like 300 bucks
and you start now you have your own
Corporation it's incredible it might be
a little more than that I don't know but
you have a businessman you can make it
happen yeah but you don't just need a
corporation to need a business you need
a bank account need a business to become
a corporation yeah so what I found is
don't incorporate until you're you have
income or you're about to start getting
income and then you incorporate because
you need to as opposed to I'm starting a
corporation be like one of these days
I'm gonna start using it no no no if if
if I'm not giving anybody advice I'll
just tell you in my personal opinion if
you as an individual are doing work you
act as a sole proprietor once you get to
a certain degree of income or you want
to start hiring then you can formalize
your corporation for those reasons if
you start taking on assets and you want
to protect you want to limit liability
then you create a limited liability
Corporation for those reasons so you can
separate your assets out from the
company and your personal assets if if
you're just like a contractor who does
odd jobs here and there you don't
necessarily need a corporation depending
on what you do but a lot of people will
create single member llc's to run their
business through to limit liability I
didn't learn it in public school which
is why I brought it up on the show I
think more people should know about it
and be taught that yeah it was tough for
me starting everything up because I had
to figure it out on my own and I had all
this different advice and and people
tell me different things and we don't do
that for our kids the fascinating thing
to me is that a kid is more likely to
learn how to bind their chest than how
to start a company no yikes has anyone
thought about that
a kid is more likely to learn how to
tuck his genitals between his legs then
he will learn how to open a bank and you
mean a public school yeah yeah not my
kids oh no so we've got this this bill
in second uh uh in New Jersey about
second graders who have to you know
learn about identity and all that stuff
and it's like shouldn't we teach these
kids about basic elements of society
before we teach them about you know
inner workings of biology it's not as if
our educational system is doing really
well our test results are higher and our
children are performing well relative to
the children in other developed
countries so we can just add all this
extra stuff on top of it I mean
Pakistan's abysmal but of course even if
our system was doing very well then
there was more to add it wouldn't be
this disgusting perverted nonsense
that's good you know going to sexually
confuse these kids the fascinating thing
to me is I remember I used to tell
people this stat that in South Africa a
little girl is more likely to be raped
than learn how to read the stats are
horrifying and now to see it in the
United States that you know a kid is
more likely to learn how to bind their
you know their breasts as opposed to
learn how to open a bank account to
start a business like that should be
alarming to people this is very alarming
to me because I asked a bunch of 11 year
old
they thought they should be learning
and they gave them a
list here's some of the things they want
to learn about sewing and repairing
things hunting and foraging money and
budgeting taxes and insurance health
care and first aid cars and mechanics
just to name a few kids are not the kind
of
they think that kids are like these
social justice widgets I think that's
what Ben Shapiro said that the public
school system views them as and they're
not children are small people that
deserve to learn about things like
opening bank accounts and starting
companies they do not need to be gender
confused by such an early age and if
there was ever anything to fight against
this is it and we don't have the choice
anymore not to fight there is no option
anymore if you value your children this
is what you have to do but I think Jack
basobic is the one who says it that
fighting back is just having a family
right yeah oh he says it all the time
have a family yeah worker work your job
Mike sternovich has Mike cernovich says
make money yeah the medium is the
message that's it the way you deliver
the message is is the message homeschool
your kids yes I was homeschooled from uh
like pre-kindergarten for for as soon as
I could communicate in any way my mom
was trying to teach me stuff we were
learning my brothers and sisters we
learned math when we were like before we
were and five I was learning how to play
chess when I was three I tell people you
know I've talked to people and they say
oh my three-year-old couldn't possibly
learn that stuff for too young and I'm
like it doesn't matter if they can start
teaching them now it may be harder for
them because they're only three but
trust me they are learning they're not
learning as fast as an adult would learn
but they are learning I hear people like
say oh it's so easier to it's so much
easier to learn a language when you're a
little kid and my response is no it
isn't how long does it take a human baby
to become fluent in English to have a
political conversation with you takes a
while sorry it takes like 20 years yeah
you know you can have a 12 year old who
can speak English to you but they're
gonna be I don't know what those
concepts mean I don't know what those
things are but a human being who's 30
years old on average I believe it takes
around 44 weeks for a European from
someone who speaks a Germanic a romance
language to learn a Dramatical romance
language and be fluent in it enough to
actually have political conversations
and it's because all of that element of
learning all that wisdom and knowledge
you've given about your life plays a
role in your ability to learn but also
it's extremely easy to say to someone
you know uh basura is garbage and they
instantly connect those because they
already understand the concepts of
language whereas it takes a you know how
long like for aside from knowledge
getting a kid to actually be able to
speak to you is what eight or ten years
before they're actually talking and
expressing like real conversations and
asking real questions so at a younger
age it's actually harder to learn things
but I just say this because
don't assume just because your kid is
three they can't learn it just will take
them longer but you should be teaching
them everything you can and you and my
my opinion on this is always speak to
your children like adults yes I always
do that if a kid says something to me
like how how do I turn on the game I'll
be like press the power button and the
remotes on top
I'm not gonna dumb it down I'm not going
to be like okay well this is the
controller here's how you use it I'm
gonna be like that's the controller pick
it up play it you'll figure it out press
the buttons until you figure out what
makes them go they'll ask you when they
need you
and let them figure it out on their own
I think exactly I remember a
conversation that I might be fabricating
this but I seem to remember this
conversation with my mom I was really
young watching Sesame Street and they're
always talking Spanish on Sesame Street
and I asked my mom like can I learn
Spanish and she said no it's too hard
and that would basically shut my mind
down to it for my entire life until I
was in my 20s and 30s and I and I became
Sovereign and I and I knew I could do
anything I wanted to do mentally
um so if you're a mom out there don't
tell your kid it's too hard tell them
yeah you can
and then learn it with them yeah
I uh I follow a bunch of these
Instagrams that are for like raising
kids from a young age and one of the
things that a majority of them recommend
is just sitting down with your baby and
reading to them and that's so
interesting to me because my siblings
and I were all homeschooled all of our
Lives except for like the last two years
of high school for me and my sister but
my parents read to us and then there
came a point where they would take our
books away from us to punish us all of
us all of us we would read under the
covers with flashlights this is how we
would get in trouble we'd get like you
know spanked for this or whatever I
don't remember how they punished this
for this but we were constantly reading
and they thought this was great all of
our vocabularies are incredibly well
developed and we're not weird
homeschooled kids people have this fear
of homeschooling they say Well they're
not going to be like other kids they're
not going to be socialized with other
kids my siblings and I were as you say
we were constantly around adults and the
adults thought that we were incredibly
Charming because we were well behaved we
knew what adults expected and we
understood that we were going to be
adults so we were working towards that
that was our goal we didn't just want to
stay kids forever and I think that's a
really huge problem with modern people
is that they want to stay kids forever
to become a real issue and I think
homeschooling is going to revolutionize
us hopefully in the near future no
that's very true and you're correct a
lot of people will say homeschool kids
are weird and they don't fit in with the
other kids like well maybe I don't want
them to fit in with the kids who are
getting vasectomies when they're 15
years old yeah seriously the little
soldiers that are being built yeah the
Little Machines I don't want my kid to
feel normal around that environment that
environment was crazy public school I
mean that environment was crazy I got
pushed in the locker I mean I think I
see kids beating each other hitting each
other's face for like what because you
know somebody looked at the other guy
wrong yeah my friend I came up and
knocked my books out of my hand one time
I was like dude me and my friends would
purposely go in the lockers and hide in
them but you wouldn't get beat up that's
the strategy
we didn't really have there's an episode
we didn't have that problem well so I
only went to high school for a couple
months but in grade school and the
public school went to there wasn't
really a big problem I got into a fight
like once I think yeah one I got into
one fight and it was with a friend of
mine yeah he was a friend of mine too
and but like we didn't really have
bullies you know it wasn't really a
thing uh there was the popular kid and
then people kind of did their thing
someone stole my Pokemon game once that
kind of pissed me off we used to walk
through the halls and the huge crowds of
kids would be walking through the Halls
all like shuffling and I'd go
because it looks like a bunch of cattle
being shuffled around so you were the
bully Ian yeah that was how I got back
yeah you guys ever see uh 30 Rock where
uh Tina face character is talking about
how everyone was always mean to her in
high school and that and then it shows
how she remembers them making fun of her
but then what actually happened is
everyone else remembers it and she was
the bully and she was I figured out why
I was bullied though in elementary
school I was really good friends with
everybody then we started playing sports
and I was really bad I had indoor eyes
because I watch TV and play video games
a lot so I couldn't hit the baseball and
my parents didn't give me help me get
getting training so we couldn't afford
it so all the kids were my friends in
elementary school just I was on their
baseball team I would strike out every
time and they we were coming last every
season so Middle School comes I'm like
why are they so me mean to me all my
friends are not they're all sitting over
there and I'm alone at this table with
the Nerds now no offense guys if you're
out there I love you still
um and now I get it looking back it was
because of my inability to integrate or
adapt with these guys and so I don't
blame them anymore how the tables have
turned because nowadays you know if a
kid of that age isn't good at video
games because he spent too much time
playing sports he's probably going to be
ostracized for sure I disagree I saw a
post um I think this was from Alexis
Ohanian former I think he was I don't
know if he's still with Reddit but he
was the founder of Reddit and he said
Sports will be the only medium to
survive because it's the only medium
with no social media digital or Internet
equivalent I think he's right inter so
when you look at uh like movies and
stuff it's online it's streaming Sports
all of that you're streaming everything
but you you need someone you you need
the physical presence of the sport
Esports obviously exists but still
people are playing the games and
actively doing things whereas everything
else is on demand you know sporting
events are still event
the people the people I know who have
cable are have it specifically for
sports at this point there's no other
reason exactly that's crazy isn't it
yeah when it comes to movies on demand
watch what you want when you want to
watch it when it comes to sporting
events it's well those events are
happening when it comes to music well
music whenever you want you don't you
don't need to go to the concert you can
watch the concert live streamed you can
re you can rerun sporting events for
sure but sporting events happen in the
real world and people want to watch the
real world versions of them so I think I
think that's a fair point I think
sporting will be the only thing to make
it yeah I do think Esports well I'm not
talking about institutional Sports I'm
just saying more and more kids are
playing video games and spending time on
social media and parents aren't putting
as much emphasis on getting them
involved in team sports how do you feel
so I don't think it's as much a like
it's it's been declining over the years
like even when I was a kid growing up in
the you know late 90s early 2000s my
parents would constantly talk about the
fact that when they were kids you'd be
outside playing you know pick up
baseball or
whatever other Sport and my generation
wasn't doing that as much uh but it's
also it's interesting because that also
depends on where you grow up because
whenever I'd be out in the city with my
cousins we'd actually be more likely to
to play outdoor sports like that in the
street admit it Sheamus you are a South
Side Chicago Troublemaker that's that's
not true all right I never went out
there to cause no trouble you know
what's funny this is really funny you
know all the gangs in Chicago are
basically like religious organizations
they're like the gangs are called the
disciples the Bishops the popes
no I've heard some of the names that's
interesting I think they're trying to uh
co-opt the good name of these religious
and clerical titles
yeah I mean they're a bunch no it's
interesting I mean not that not the SDS
right they're
what is that dusties the same disciples
Saint disciples and then there's like
different sects of each of these of
these gangs with like there's there were
the almighty popes the insane popes and
I'm like why are they the popes like
there's one Pope you know what if they
were like the imams or something my
friend was like what's next the choir
boys
were you what was your past like did you
grow up like indoor or were you playing
a lot of sports uh you know I I
definitely played Sports when I was
young in elementary school and stuff I
didn't so much get into in them in high
school but then actually I really got
into that kind of stuff actually in
college I got into mixed martial arts
and and that kind of stuff and Judo and
so it's not something that was a big
part of my high school but it's
something I came to appreciate a little
later so I when you know I wouldn't go
to watch a ton of uh sporting events but
then you know with UFC and stuff would
go out and watch the big fights that
kind of thing I have such a mixed
feeling on Athletics I know there's mad
value in athletics and having kids
wrestle and play and stuff but I would
play basketball and they would throw
elbows at my face and I'm like first off
I don't want to get my cheekbone broken
second of all I don't want to break that
guy's cheekbone and it's going to be one
or the other if you keep throwing elbows
so I stop or or you can skate
well I fell off and dislocated my left
toe and I've missed our Washing DC trip
so I was like well F that I'm not
skating again
just start first day
that hurt we used to go to cross country
come on dude no pain okay this is why
you got bullies my friends were like we
went to Costco I was like I'm gonna do
cross-country my sophomore year high
school what my friends are doing I'm
doing it we go and they're like okay
first thing conditioning two hours a day
after school you're gonna be Pumping
Iron running I'm like what the hell am I
doing I feel so much pain I'm not
enjoying a moment of it like what is the
purpose of running I run to get
somewhere I don't run for fun
I'm not I'm not a fan of running I like
skating I don't like team sports I like
individual sports you know uh action
sports are more are are in a sense
similar to like martial arts it's an
individual you're driving yourself
you're you're pursuing something that
you want to attain you accomplish your
goals there's no cheating you can't lie
I mean you can lie but people don't care
they're like you know show me the video
If you claim to do the trick it's like
oh I I did a front board down that 15
stair rail it's like no you didn't do we
know you're lying we know you can't do
that that's well beyond your
capabilities
but it's about you the only thing that
really matters when you're skating is
can I overcome myself every day you're
doing it for yourself to to drive to
grow to better yourself and you get fit
in the process and it hurts all the time
it's called paying your dues whenever
someone Falls paying your dues oh paying
yeah so whenever someone Falls I'm like
you gotta pay your dues you know you
know you you don't get to you know
launch off an eight foot ramp 10 12 feet
in the air and then come down 300 times
without taking one slam and hurting your
elbow
pay your doozy and no pain no gain
you're gonna say something oh I was just
gonna say that's one of the great things
about something like Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
is it's something that teaches you like
you can't be a jerk all the time because
like every single day you get on the mat
and someone is immediately better than
you when you step in they're choking you
out every single time they're tapping
you out all the time and so you have to
be humbled you have to learn to tell
someone like yep you could have totally
killed me right there and then I have to
get back on the mat with that person and
learn to do it again and get better and
better better so there's a
self-improvement but there's also
humility aspect at the same time and the
people who succeed over time I think are
are usually you know the people who can
take that on and learn from it I think
it's really beneficial for people yeah
absolutely and I I can't speak so much
to Jujitsu but I would agree I think
actually self-improvement in humility or
indispensable to one another I mean you
cannot improve unless you're willing to
acknowledge that you got perfect you
guys ever see that episode of South Park
about sarcastible yeah
the kids getting hurt so they're all
like they're playing football with like
balloons or whatever oh yeah that's
where we're going everybody gets a
trophy I was playing flag football
because I was like well the one sport I
love is flag football because you don't
have to Ram into each other and so we
were throwing the block caught the balls
running so fast so fast that I tore my
MCL just by running I was my mind was it
can make my body do things that the body
can't handle and I had to learn that
lesson in a bloody two-week healing I
didn't have any health insurance I just
massaged it and held my hands on it for
like two or three weeks as I limped
around and to this day it's not the same
yeah my goal when I have kids is to have
them do solo sports like rollerblading
or skateboarding or skiing or
snowboarding and also have them do team
sports because I really feel like both
of these different facets teach you
different skills and I feel like you
should probably have both of them like
teach your daughters how to dance you
got to teach them all how to like I
don't know program computers there's
lots of fun stuff you can do I think
that Sports is just one of the things
that kids really need to engage with to
really see how interesting physical
fitness is and how good they can be at
it gives them such a sense of
accomplishment I think it's really
powerful parents in my opinion should be
teaching should be making their kids
learn something yes be it a sport or an
instrument but they should also be
around other kids doing it so they have
a community of peers that Inspire them
to you know better themselves I think
one of the problems with a lot of um you
know a lot of people friends of mine
have been growing when we were growing
up they're like my parents make me do
this or that it's like my mom's making
making me go to piano lessons I don't
want to go well the reason they want to
go is because we were all going to hang
out at the park
if they were hanging out playing you
know in band with a with a group of kids
and writing songs they'd be like Oh yay
I'm really excited my friends my mom's
dropping me off with my friends to play
music
so that was always fascinating me like
why don't you like playing piano I love
playing guitar I go and hang out with my
friends and play the guitar we write
songs ah none of your friends play piano
or play music they do other things one
of the biggest problems you know I
noticed when I was growing up was how
many parents had their kids do literally
nothing they'd be like ah they're kids
it's like well what do you mean they're
kids well they're just gonna go ride
their bikes and play games when I was
when I was you know 10 13 I was doing
Flash animation
I was making websites on flash I was
reading news I was developing my own
video games I was building my own
computers I was learning how to play the
guitar and the drums and I was
skateboarding all of those things and I
love doing all those things why was I
doing them though for one I'm very much
you know always been self-driven and
curious and I wanted to learn how to do
things I wanted to like make these games
I want to make them better I thought
they were done wrong but also my friends
for the most part at the skate park were
skating I had another group of friends
that had a band and if I wanted to hang
out with them during band like I had to
play an instrument
I had a bunch of friends who had
computers and were on the internet and
built their own computers and were
hacking stuff and I was like oh yeah
when I come home from skating and
playing music I can go on AIM and talk
to them and we can Goof Off so there was
actually a community that you know
encouraged me to do this as well
what were your guys man like play things
that you would do growing up
well I called in to talk radio when I
was like in fifth grade so I'm a very
normal person I have a very particular
brain and so yeah I love that Gathering
I tried calling to talk radio they'd
never take my calls I was gonna say I
used to write letters to the editor when
I was like nine and some of them got
published and I was always so proud I
used to I used to hang out at a comic
shop playing Pokemon and Magic the
Gathering and we would we would get
there super early as soon as they opened
on Saturday we'd watch Dragon Ball Z in
the background we would play When the
Dragon Ball Z card game card game came
out we'd play that we'd play Pokemon
eventually we stopped playing Pokemon
because it was just when the Japanese
cards made it over and there they
weren't regulated properly none of us
had the money to compete so we started
playing Magic we started drafting but by
around noon we're all boards we'd grab
our skateboards and we go skate around
the neighborhood for a few hours we
leave our backpack to the card shop then
come back later when everyone's Drafting
and getting like we would do with bikes
that was very similar in the early days
we I would um I played a lot of videos
as much as video games as I could since
I I was like three Atari but then my mom
be like get off that video games and
throw me out of the house and stuff get
out of here just be outside for three
hours so I started making movies
yeah this is why you're getting money
oh you only run to get something we're
gonna get anywhere um but so I started
play acting we'd go around the
neighborhood and be like okay I'm John
and you're Lisa now and then we'd be
like characters and then I got into
acting later in life that was but I
don't think I would have done that if
she didn't kick me off the video games
over and over I'm concerned about the
metaverse it was it was a it was a it
was actually a heartwarming story
until the drugs well it's still
heartwarming
let's talk about let's talk about this
one other story just totally off just
random uh from timcast.com South
Carolina schedules first execution since
completion of firing squad chamber whoa
is this a picture of it South Carolina
has scheduled its first execution of a
death row inmate since completing the
firing squad chamber is is it now now
hold on there a minute guys are you
saying they're going to firing squad
this person
they say executions in the state have
been halted for the last decade due to
the difficulty of obtaining the drugs
used for Lethal Injections leaving 35
death row inmates in limbo last year
they made the electric chair their
primary method for carrying out death
but said that they would give inmates an
option to choose death by firing squad
or lethal injection panel
which would you prefer lethal injection
electric chair firing squad
all right I'm definitely going to go
with firing squad for the coolness
Factor though I'm pretty sure the Lethal
Injections probably uh not the most
painful though it is the most painful it
could be like I guess it depends on how
because the cocktail's been messed up
before right no no no it literally is
okay yeah they paralyze you first so you
can't express the pain ah but uh it's my
understanding because I read a lot about
it is that lethal injection is actually
a slow excruciating death
no I would think that electric chair
would be the worst right yeah but yeah
but yeah no I would go with fire your
eyes like don't they like boil and burst
out here oh my gosh
I think carbon monoxide poisoning I
don't know why they don't do that they
that would be painless yeah they
actually do they have these suicide pots
where they gradually increase the level
of carbon wait oh yeah where was that
like it's Sweden or something yeah we
talked about that before the suicide
boots I picked firing somebody watched
too much feature out there exactly gross
but I'd have to take the firing I think
I'd take the firing squad firing squad
yeah honestly I think firing squad would
probably be the least painful did they
get rid of it because they didn't want
the soldiers to feel guilty about like
who hit the killing bullet no no that's
why they do it yeah exactly no one knows
who actually killed the person right I
think one of them has a gun with blanks
in it or something like that really yeah
interesting wow and so you could be the
one where the and then the blanks yeah
that's perfect but it's also it's it's I
mean I guess the problem with the firing
squad is like what if they all hit your
stomach
[Music]
right at your heart I don't know to be
honest what do you guys think of well
first of all so I oppose the death
penalty I don't I would prefer none of
these things and um the issue I have
with it is if you've contained someone
already I don't see a reason to end
their life like they're they're not
don't let them out obviously if they're
like serious offenders but if they're
like locked in a concrete box
what sucks is like you got to pay for
them you've got to pay for their food
and their life and everything and that's
more than a lot of people deserve that's
for sure but then it's just a scary
thought to me to be like killing people
you know what I mean yeah but how is
locking them away forever working right
we don't do that like that's the problem
is that we we do all this early release
stuff you know something comes out you
have covet issues or you know someone
can be rehabilitated that would be a
better option that actually used to be
right that was the worst penalty you
could receive in in a lot of cultures
was you know you just were you know sent
to the Hinterlands and you couldn't but
but now but you know Global Community
it's not as big a punishment as it used
to be I mean if let's let's play this
game um electric chair lethal injection
firing squad or they put you in a little
dinghy and kick you off into the ocean
I take the ocean on that one you see
most people would be like yeah but
that's just you starve to death either
you starve me finally they kick you out
into it into international waters and
say good luck
at least got a chance yeah that what do
you think other countries would say
they'd be like dude your murderers are
washing up on our floors they go they go
They're not setting their best okay
they're not sending their best to us I
mean I guess there's like Islands you
know you can just eat coconuts or
whatever so what do you guys think about
death and are you for the death penalty
what do you guys think no that penalty's
bad you're pretty against it by Nature
what Sheamus what are you feeling I'm
not yeah I don't uh I I yeah against I
would say I lean towards against but
it's it's not something I've completely
worked out
what do you think yeah I'm Pro like you
you have a situation where uh people do
heinous things you need a good deterrent
you need to send a message for those
things and like I said also the and you
know the indefinite uh incarceration
thing I think is in often crueler but on
top of that is also extremely costly and
unlikely to occur in the long run as
societies find ways to release these
here's my question for you how many
innocent people are you willing to kill
to guarantee you kill the bad guys well
again though this is always the question
of all rule enforcement throughout all
Society right how many innocent people
are we willing to walk away in prison
how many innocent people are we willing
to kill and the answer is you're always
going to have fault any any legal system
is going to have some level of failure I
I got it I got it but how many innocent
people would you personally be willing
to kill to make sure the bad guys get
killed again I don't have a hard number
but it wouldn't be zero greater than one
yeah uh you see that I have a problem
with that right if there's but one
righteous person I I I I I don't trust
the state I don't try trust people like
Kamala we've seen how she's acted
towards people who were who should have
been released from prison uh people who
had evidence exonerating them and her
and her Department was like no we're
gonna keep them anyway
um the state has more often shown that
it's willing to cover up its faults
because they don't want people to
realize they execute innocent people so
they'll lie about it and execute
innocent people and uh it is better than
100 guilty persons Escape than one isn't
person suffer my solution to that I
suppose is called the Second Amendment I
look at what the founding fathers had in
mind don't have innocent people suffer
everybody gets guns and I'm like okay
well that means there may be accidents
there may be conflict but you you leave
more up to the individuals to defend
themselves it's their personal
responsibility and you leave more up to
uh the state I mean the state backs away
from potentially killing innocent people
which it has even even in the founding
father's time the the issue I I find
here with the death penalty is
if the if the amount of innocent people
is greater than one then the state is
murdering innocent people and I don't
think it's worth it if you've locked
someone in a box they can't get out the
worst case scenario in in this
circumstance is you've got an innocent
person locked in a box but at least
you're not killing them and making an
innocent person walk down death row to
an electric chair or a firing squad or a
lethal injection because just imagine
being that person and them saying hey
look we get it you might be innocent but
hey systems got to do it the system does
ah I say screw that man lock the person
in the box lock them away there's 35
people it sucks but my attitude is I
would personally rather pay
what I could to keep these people locked
up permanently than to be party to the
execution of an innocent person but it's
not easy though but imagine you're that
family right you're the you're the
family of that victim and now you have
to watch this person you know spend a
you know five ten years and then getting
out early I don't believe in retribution
so that's you know not a I don't care I
I think you should I think that that's I
think that that's part of Justice I
think that when you take someone's life
you should pay for it I think that when
you hurt another person's family that's
something you should pay for I think
Justice should be retributed in many
ways like eye for an eye how far do you
go eye for an eye I mean again you know
obviously we can we you can get lost in
how harsh you can get but I think that a
system that says oh this is only for
deterrence sake or this is only you know
that it should never it should never be
uh you know retributed is is outweighing
the rights of the criminal more than the
rights of the victims and I think that
sends a message and I think over time it
always devolves into a scenario where
people are getting fewer sentences
released early they're being soft on
these things and you inevitably end up
in a situation that we are now where we
have we have crimes that aren't punished
in any of these I don't think those
things correlate like the reason
criminals are being released is because
the left is advocating for their release
for stupid reasons we should have many
people should be in prison much longer
and many people should be in prison much
less non-violent drug offenses it's like
come on uh but then you get violent
offenders who commit murder and get out
in a few years now that's a problem I
don't I don't think retribution makes
sense and eye for an eye leaves the
whole world blind everyone's got a
grievance against somebody else and they
all want retribution for their perceived
slights and what happens when up report
uh when a victim falsely accuses someone
or wrongly because they're emotionally
driven and and driven by Passion instead
of logic so the state often it's
supposed to try its best to sort the
facts and make sure that it's proven
Beyond a Beyond A Reasonable Doubt often
they do often we've seen circumstances
where people like Kamala are willing to
you leave people to rotten prison even
if they're innocent her Department her
office did this
um that's what's been reported that's
how that's how it's been reported and uh
and then I'm supposed to sit back and
just trust the state that they're not
making mistakes and that the retribution
is just what happens if the state
executes an innocent person because the
family wanted retribution am I let's say
a family member of mine is on death row
and the families like they did it I know
they did it and so they say we demand
retribution and the state says and we're
going to grant that retribution execute
my friend or family member and then a
day later evidence comes out exonerating
them am I entitled to retribution
against the Executioner do I get to put
him on death row because he killed my
loved one the answer should be yes right
where's my retribution against the state
for killing an innocent person that I
loved you don't get it so the problem is
there is no retribution the state kills
people to shut people up they they let
rioters Riot because they don't want to
call because they don't care they put
innocent people in prison in these riots
they arrest innocent people because they
want to avoid riots this is the problem
with the state you just you can't trust
them you can trust them sometimes for
some things you can cross your fingers
but if the issue is they are not
completely trustworthy then we can't
allow the state to take extreme or
permanent actions because we can't ever
confirm 100 what they're doing is right
you shouldn't trust anyone really in
that situation that's up to you to
survive on this reality floor uh I used
to be very pro-death penalty without a
question like yeah if they're if they're
a killer and they're not going to stop
kill them get them out of here but then
I started to think about the Nazis and
man they would just execute people at
will and so are the Soviets and like so
I didn't I have a very American Blinder
on when I think about things and Malice
Michael Mouse is really opened my eyes
to this so as well as Luke rukowski uh
coming from the Soviet Union their
families are from the Soviet Union it's
like yo the state is not like the
benevolent God that you think it is I
was really indoctrinated growing up but
wouldn't you say that different
governments do things for different
reasons so like regardless of how you
feel about the death penalty couldn't
you say well you know when Stalin and
Hitler were killing people for bad
reasons that didn't necessarily mean
there couldn't be good reasons for
another government to do and again this
is someone who I've acknowledged I don't
really have a fleshed out position yeah
you could kill for a good I think you
could kill for a good reason to be
honest there's there's a scaling
question in the death penalty and it it
pertains to war right uh someone like
Hitler or Stalin yeah those people died
and those people died because you're in
war and they're actively killing and
massacring by the millions and you're
trying to actively stop them my question
is if someone's been actively stopped
already and you know it's like the I
suppose there's the the great
philosophical question has been has been
asked answered in many ways in many of
these Batman comics the the Injustice
storyline you guys fans of DC at all you
know when uh Joker depending on which
version of the storyline Joker drugs uh
Superman Superman kills Lois Superman
loses it and he's like to Batman if you
just killed this man these people
wouldn't have died or there's like
another story I I can't remember which
one it is but you know Joker plants a
nuke and blows up metropolis and
Superman's like you could have killed
him and saved millions and then and um
Damien Wayne this isn't the video game I
think it's from the comic as well he's
like you've had every opportunity to
stop these murderers and you don't
Batman won't do it and they get out they
murder again and he's like enough and
then you know the Justice League goes
dark and they're like just executing
criminals and stuff there's great
philosophical questions about how to
handle things my issue ultimately comes
down to I just don't talk I don't trust
the state I don't I've I've I've seen a
lot of people I don't trust them these
big cities are run by corrupt lunatics
and um I think Kamala Harris should
should terrify people yeah we have laws
in place so you don't have to trust the
state the large let's trust the law yeah
okay he was about to say something I
wanted I was gonna say that your first
gulp of inept government will turn you
into libertarian but I think at the
bottom of that glass
competent government is the key because
it's very tempting to say when you look
at a government that's corrupt and inept
to say just get government out of
everything that's the easy thing right
this is what the right has been doing
and Libertarians have been doing for
many years we'll just get my kids out of
the government school then I don't have
to worry what's being taught there we'll
just get my kids away from this
influence you know what happened
happening in the media well I'll just uh
start my own business and then I don't
have to care what's going on with these
things saying that if we just keep
exiting each one of these Arenas that
eventually you know you will be able to
solve the problem but the issue is that
that never solves the problem they
always end up coming after you you never
just get to get away right and so the
the easy out is to say we just take the
power of government away right this is
this is what we're we're taught is that
we just reduce the power of government
we or we put checks and balances the
limit on the power of government and
then therefore we don't have to worry
what government does because there's the
system that holds it holds it in check
for us the truth is that at the end of
the day that doesn't work that never
works the government always retains that
power someone's always making these
decisions of the state and they are
always taking that power they're always
increasing and centralizing the power
the question is who wields it you want
someone competent you don't just want to
pretend like you can run away forever
all right we gotta go to super chats if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this YouTube channel
share the show everywhere you can if you
really want to help us out we are
completely marketed through Grassroots
means I was actually thinking maybe we
should make a commercial for the show
and do like our first ever marketing run
we've never done anything like that
um maybe we'll do like an ad spot on
YouTube or something or some other
podcasts but um I don't know I always
just assumed If people really liked the
show they would just share it because
they liked it so if you do there you go
also check out timcast.com become
members support our work directly new
episodes of the members only Tim cast
irrell show Monday through Thursday at
8pm we have a huge Library go watch all
of it let's read some of these super
chats we got Jeremy Gardner who says I'm
a server of 15 years and loved your
conversation about servers last week
tips have everything to do with culture
and nothing to do with race I can tell
what someone will tip me 99 out of 100
times
people can never I always tip insane
amounts like 200 300 and it's funny you
know we went out to eat today and the
servers were actually like do you want
to take this this group another lady was
like
I guess sure I'll take them and she's
like okay thanks and then I'm like wow I
wonder if that lady who's like you like
gave up us as a group regrets it because
we tipped like 200 bucks and so the
other lady was probably just like yes
and then the other server was like no
that's how it goes man you never know
all right Adam Noel says hey Tim cast
crew my name is Adam Noel and I just
emailed you guys a song to spin the UFO
please look for political punk rock
opera Tim get ready well all right we'll
take a look you want to write that down
I got it
blue heart says her name is stretching
Gretchen what is that a reference to
doing yoga or something
most likely oh does she she does yoga I
don't know interesting I'm just trying
to Veer away from the uh the dirty
thoughts
Chris Larson says hey Tim I live in
South Dakota and Christy gnome banned
teaching CRT in schools not sure if you
knew or not but I think it's very
interesting
I I suppose the issue is they just go
well we're not teaching critical race
Theory we're just applying critical race
Theory to what we teach practice Yeah
practice that's right
Jason Fisher says speaking of Dennis
Prager you should have someone from
prageru in the show in the show we could
have we certainly could I don't know who
should we have from uh from Prager
Dennis himself that'd be great that'd be
great he's smart I've had will Witt in
my channel he's a good guy oh yeah well
what oh yeah yeah Don's Herald says your
discussion on religion yesterday was the
best I've seen yet if you want a
thought-provoking look into the
Afterlife check out C.S Lewis's the
great divorce easily my favorite short
story yes uh yesterday with Andrew
Clavin we talked religion over at
timcast.com and the members only second
it was really really good yeah it was
intense it was a lot of fun I love the
great divorce that C.S Lewis is one of
my favorite authors of all time what's
it what's it about uh it's about this
guy who goes on a trip and he doesn't
really realize it but it turns out he's
in hell and he's been traveling to
heaven and as he goes through this like
slowly little bits of his pride are
taken away as like the angel reveals the
things that are holding him back into
hell and he starts seeing all the all
the foolish things he's been trying to
hold on to it's really excellent oh wow
cool
young Pei Chang says hi guys Oren I've
read your tweets retweeted for Michael
malice and I've referenced some of your
videos when trying to explain to other
folks about the definition of a midwit
yeah no yeah one of my bigger videos was
on uh was explaining uh mid-wittery and
kind of what that means and where that
comes from we're in the middle of a
Midway midwit epidemic so you have an
elevator pitch on midwits yeah basically
a midwit is someone who is just slightly
above average intelligence and so
because they're just slightly above
average it's one of the things that
defines them like they're smarter than
most people like they're smart people
but they're never the smartest person in
the room and because they're never the
smartest person in the room they're
always reaching for it they always want
to prove themselves the the smartest
person personal room you know they're
they know what they're doing it's like
someone who knows how to fight you know
they don't need to prove that they they
know they don't have to go around
talking tough because they know it
midwits in the same scenario and be so
because of that they like to learn
things like little bits of language this
is why you know wokeness and
progressivism is so attractive to a
midwit because by keeping up on the
jargon they can look more intelligent
than they are they can use that as a
weapon have you seen that video where
they ask everyone to judge people uh
based on how they look on their
intelligence and there's one woman where
she's just like I can tell you're not
very smart and then they'll take IQ
tests and then they're told to sit down
from smartest to least smart and the
woman who is really cocky turns out to
be like the stupidest person oh yeah
that wouldn't surprise me at all that
was funny do you think that the people
in Bill Maher's audience were midwits
because that was important thing I
thought yeah yeah yeah absolutely so one
of the things about mid-wittery is like
when when you learn things when you're
young you learn them at a low resolution
right you learn very simple things about
them sometimes they're actually
completely wrong but you have to learn
kind of a wrong version before you as a
young person you can eventually grasp
the more complex version what midwits do
is they learn to deconstruct that
child's version of understanding things
like God or the history of America like
they they treat and they learn to
deconstruct that stuff and they think
because they're deconstructing the
simplistic version they're very
intelligent and they're rewarded in the
educational system and and popular
culture for doing this and so they keep
doing it even to adulthood they never
learn about the more complicated version
but they think think they're being very
intelligent they're smart enough to know
they're not smart enough yeah and so
there there was a guy that um my friends
knew who was
um mentally uh developmentally disabled
but he was smart enough to know he was
and it was like a weird position because
like he was limited in what he could do
but he was also cognizant of that fact
so it's like a lot of these midwits are
that way they're on Twitter they're not
successful people they know they're
smarter than most people but they're not
smart enough to run a business or
survive or succeed so they end up just
angry
they they deserve more don't they and so
I think you see a lot of that with the
with the woke activists they they assume
that the system must be broken because
certainly someone as smart as them
should have money and and wealth and
fame and power instead they got 20 000
followers on Twitter and they can't pay
their bills yeah it's a problem with
public school system makes people feel
like a success when they get all A's but
man they're not prepared for the real
world all right young says Tim Elijah
Schaefer said he will be doing things in
Nashville Nashville next week too are
you guys going to be doing something
together there also Sheamus your
appearance on Matt frad's Channel helped
me impress a new Catholic friend oh well
thank you so much
um
we are we do have plans to bring Elijah
on one of those evenings oh it's great I
love that guy man Mr Shiva
John Boyle says yo Tim when will be when
will we be able to watch the IRL and
members segment live over at
timcastiro.com the member segments are
recorded and then uploaded but as for
the show itself well you know what we
need we need a uh a web dev backend and
like webmaster kind of person yeah we
need someone who knows how to do all the
code how to handle all the WordPress
plugins Integrations API all that stuff
so uh we're actually looking so um I
guess jobs at timcast.com and then
hopefully someone here can filter
through that and try and figure out you
know how to get somebody a job
because we are we are actually in uh
what's what's the right way to describe
it we are we need to hire someone like
by Monday yeah yeah and the tech we're
working on with uh the the foundation
that we're building is uh it's it's
still pre-alpha so it's like just too
early to do that with timcast.com just
yet but I would really like to do that
eventually
all right wait I saw another Super Chat
and I have to find it
uh now I feel bad it was great because
someone else replied to the Super Chat
oh well maybe maybe if I uh go through
it again I can find it
give me a give me a quick second here
guys Lydia I just want to tell you I
love you by the way man you're awesome
oh
okay it's right here so uh Jeff
Lineberger says thanks for getting me
through the two and a half hours of
traffic every day here in California
what do you think is a good platform for
more art based political content Rumble
doesn't seem suited for that um
I don't know Sheamus you're the artist
I was looking for this this you weren't
even paying attention by the way I found
it it's from Jubilee it's it's a video
where they have strangers rank each
other's Intelligence on a scale of one
to six what's a good platform for art
art based political content oh man I
mean I'm still using YouTube look at me
and it's difficult to patreon well yeah
so so well we're working on a paywall on
the website now so give me a break but
so uh it's difficult to format for
different social media websites too so
like the aspect ratios change when we do
YouTube I can just upload the videos in
1920 by 1080 when I do Tick Tock I have
to reanimate all the characters so
they're pretending they have Tourette's
so the the the follow-up there was from
Adrian Contreras says I feel you Jeff
I'm on the 101 right now by Thousand
Oaks it's brutal shout out to our
friends who are stuck in traffic
together while I was listening to the
show The Struggle all right
Austin L says hey Tim have you noticed
we keep saying woke companies hate us
and they never deny it they never say of
course we don't hate our customers it's
just the Silence of them not disagreeing
with that statements yeah they hate
their customers they really do
uh it's it's it's it's sad but I do kind
of feel like a lot of the stuff is
falling apart
they've got some new Marvel shows coming
out and they're just like it's it's lost
luster yeah I feel like the Marvel
movies they're probably gonna make money
but we've been culturally stagnant for a
long time and that Jeremy's razors
commercial was awesome and it had last I
looked at over seven million views you
want to talk about as long as that stuff
is degrading but you can also see the
growth where it's growing and that's
with Julie wired man think about how
much daily wire is going to make off of
what do they have like 70 000 Razer
subscribers now or something ridiculous
oh I don't know that's awesome they're
probably making so much money off that
it's like the daily wire shuts down
because they're like well we were making
hundreds of millions off of the razors
and we just figured we didn't need to
meet it anymore yeah that's the way it
uses than content right yes yeah check
those out crank them out huh no but they
wouldn't do that they're gonna do more
they're doing kids shows Jay says
Sheamus are you going down to Nashville
too you should have a debate with Ben
using your impression of him have
Candace be the judge should be a load of
laughs okay so here's what actually
would happen if I went down to Nashville
and talked to Ben Shapiro as benjamira
he would get so intimidated by my
ability to impersonate him he'd had an
identity crisis and then he would become
Freedom tunes and if Ben Shapiro was
making Freedom Tunes instead of me that
would be a disaster okay folks yeah it
would be like you both would be
mirroring each other and saying the same
things and then like energy would start
to mass and a singularity would form it
would be like yeah
it would be the uh again it's too late
gang honestly it's too late it would be
like this dialogue it would be like the
dialogue based equivalent to that scene
in Duck Soup where the mirror breaks and
the guy on the other side of the mirror
is uh trying to imitate Groucho Marx
have you guys not seen dark suit this
classic comedy this is like this
incredible stuff yeah right it was a
great scene where I believe it's uh
Chico is trying to sneak through
Groucho's house or the character
Groucho's playing the beer breaks and
then he's in the mirror dress as him
trying to imitate all of his actions
right very good yes and that'll be me
and Ben I am familiar
yeah Sheamus we'll be we'll be coming
down yes
Jacob says you've talked about how
strong your magic the Gathering
Commander decks are what commanders do
you run
um I've got kikijiki it's insane by the
way and I think that may be one of the
most powerful because deck is I mean it
was crazy we were playing recently and I
was I was mono screwed and then Ian was
like doing really well and then I got
what's what's that what's that troll who
generates Mana for health you know I'm
talking about you pay three life for one
red it's insane and then I won just like
that it's so stupid I was like I'm at
three but you're dead I play Erza but
it's not even fun anymore because I have
to take like 39 Moves In One turn which
I like but it just ended up ruining the
game with my own Joy overload what about
you Warren Yeah well yeah this is the
problem with Commander it degenerates
into you know it's supposed to be a fun
formatted multiplayer and everybody just
tries to end up winning on turn one so
my commander deck's pretty casual
because I try to play with friends that
that keep it pretty casual I've got uh I
think mariki baru's the way to to
pronounce it where she just steals all
your permanence and then when she untaps
she kills them so you can just tap or
none tap her over again to take over the
board oh that's fun Nathan Devon says
huge fan just got kicked out of the Air
Force active duty for refusing the jab
yo that's crazy man like during a war in
Eastern Europe too that sounds like a
really bad idea well there we go
Christina H says thank you Ian but that
summary was a little off one second
after us about a man trying to save his
family and small town after the US is
hit with an EMP attack inspired me to
buy emergency food and prep before it
was cool oh wow okay thanks I just read
what it was on the uh I think it was on
Amazon or something what I read yeah
thank you for clarifying I I recently
um when they announced the food
shortages like we've already got
emergency food but considering how many
people work here like we don't really
have enough but I uh uh I bought a bunch
because uh I think inflation is going to
hit and you're like if nothing ends up
happening in the worst case scenario you
see food so I always recommend people
take care of themselves take take care
of themselves my friends
Michael Scott Matthews says are you also
anti-circumcision Tim if we oppose any
permanent physical changes to a child's
body when they can't consent informally
yes I think that's wrong I think it's a
I think it's I I don't understand the
the why we still have that you know
whatever but uh honest I will give a
shout out to
um who are those YouTube animators flash
gets with one of the funniest videos
where it's the uh the feminist and she
like goes to an aquarium and Demands a
job and they're like are you a biologist
and she's like she got all angers at
screaming about sexism and then in the
end she's she's like screaming about
patriarchy and smashing up and rioting
and then all of a sudden men's rights
activists show up and they're like oh no
men's rights activists and then the guy
goes we want our four skins back oh my
gosh this show is so funny that's fair
yeah yeah but um I don't think we should
be surgically altering children yeah
Minds up that amount of pain at that
early age well there's some Nuance here
uh you know a lot of people obviously
pointed out cleft lip surgery
reconstructive surgery for Burns and
stuff no I get that someone mentioned
that kids will have like ears that stick
out and they'll get them pinned I
disagree with that too yeah that's weird
right I don't like it if you got big
ears you got big ears it's okay I don't
know man just like kids want to make fun
of you for having big ears but I guess I
don't know like kids got to be taught to
be confident in themselves and to be
ashamed of themselves telling a kid your
ears are ugly we better get you to a
doctor to surgically alter that instead
of saying tell those kids to shut up who
cares yeah you are better
that's an opportunity to teach them I
was going to say too that I learned a
while ago that they used to not
administer pain medicine when they did
circumcisions and I was like they do
well there was there was a belief that
children couldn't feel pain or infants
at that age couldn't feel pain so they
did all sorts of medical procedures
without anesthetizing them first that's
like lifelong trauma has got to be
horrible
James says Tim Fitness is a specific
evolutionary term that refers to how
many offspring an organism has that
survives to reproduce it never had
anything to do with the smartest or
strongest ah well touche I stand
corrected good point
young says Tim if Bill Maher is lazy
would have David French he's sleeping
Scott says let he who hath no rifle sell
his Xbox and buy one Jesus probably
probably yeah well he did say if you
don't have a sword sell your clothes
that is fascinating to me
because because it's funny when people
make fun of the right for buying guns
and they're like Jesus would you know
tell them and blah blah it's like oh
he said to get a sword man but I think
it's important if you can't defend
yourself your friends and your family
from Evil then what do you do lay down
and just get steamrolled yeah yeah
that's the idea
it just doesn't sound right man some
someone's fishy all right ckcc Chris
says while we should be concerned and
learn our lessons from Nuremberg uh but
that concern should not stand in the way
of getting to the truth and holding
those who have perverted our public
accountable to the laws we know to be
right
right I think someone brought up
Nuremberg I think you did what was it
about the Nuremberg you were talking
about Jesus pardon me no it was when we
were talking about McCarthyism and you
said I don't want to you know have a Tit
for Tat yeah start doing investigations
or whatever important thing to remember
about McCarthy you know the government
and the entertainment industry actually
was full of Communists yeah that's true
an important thing to remember
well says are y'all planning any meetups
while in Nashville for your fans and Tim
cast members our family are huge Freedom
Tunes fans and I'd love the chance to
chat with Ian about graphene and
abolishing the Fed so I don't I don't
know if we have any direct plans right
now uh in the future we are planning
perhaps monthly uh excursions where we
send the mobile Studio out to various
cities and and we will do what we want
to do is Friday night IRL live so we do
the show on a stage in a big theater
somewhere in a city
love it and also thank you so much for
the shout out and also check out this
shirt that somebody sent me oh snap
me about graphene
how cool would it be if we came to your
city and then on a Friday night at a you
know thousand seater venue or whatever
everybody came in and we were we were
doing the show live on a stage and you
know uh like Alex Jones would be there
it feels like the way it's just supposed
to be
like we should do it yeah and then it
would make a live studio all the
audience like how they do all the other
late night time we can do real questions
man that's because you pay to get in and
then that's basically your Super Chat
hopefully you'll be one of the people
that can talk
I think people would be able to yell I
don't know if we we would be able to do
audience questions though yeah instead
of super chat or we could do super chats
super chats allow us to screen from
trolls is is the issue right yeah just a
bunch of people getting up are gonna
start yelling stuff and I don't know how
to be able to handle that but to be fair
I feel like we would handle that kind of
adversity really well and with Matt
Walsh it's always interesting when
people try to troll him and it never
works yeah but there's a difference
between being live
and having people go up and scream a
bunch of racial slurs as opposed to
someone asking you a question that's
hard yeah so one of the things that they
do with Matt's events is they make sure
that the people who get in are like
really good faith actors it's hard I
know it's tough it's tough yeah you know
I don't know we don't want we don't
people troll when people protest maybe
for the hazard show we could do audience
questions and then oh good point yeah
yeah we would definitely need to be able
to do that'd be fun yeah
so yes all right Brendan says you've
convinced me to watch Star Trek what is
the best series to start with from what
you've said next generation seems pretty
legit but look that's my that's my uh
demographic that's my age range when I
was a little kid you know I'm three or
four this show is on the air and I'm
sitting on the couch while my dad's
watching it so I grow up watching this
show for several years for a lot of
people the original series is is you
know it was this original for me but and
and the second one was cheesy next gen
was cheesy at first but I think it was
season two this is weird it is by far
the superior Star Wars Star Trek of
those two I don't I didn't even watch
the other ones I couldn't get into them
that that's next generation is amazing
that's why you still see Brent Steiner
and you know uh what's his name Jordy
Jordy uh doing commercials and stuff
majority
come on man he taught you to read and
this is all you can do for eating
rainbow shout out come on Levar and you
said Steiner oh is it not Brett Steiner
what's that Steiner spinner Brett you're
a great Independence Day boo oh yeah and
then they brought him back and the pre
and the sequel and they made him gay you
see that one what did they make him gay
in there yeah yeah that slip past me
yeah he's uh uh him and the other
scientists end up getting married or
something
he was amazing in the first one yeah
it's it's weird to me that they added
that to the store that didn't need to be
there because he wasn't like like we
don't
I understand if they make a movie and
there's a protagonist and the
protagonist is gay and his love is a
motivation I don't understand when they
just take a random ancillary character
and then add a gay relationship as a
plot point that hasn't changed the plot
at all oh I understand
that's their whole goal but also that
film I forgot that that happened and I
think that's because the film was just
so forgettable overall that I couldn't
take anything away from it yeah that was
not good the funny thing is they recast
um what's her face who's what's the
actress's name she was um she was on
Arrested Development she was in Scott
Pilgrim she's the voice of Katara you
guys know who I'm talking about the
young girl or the sister the older woman
in what we mean in uh Arrested
Development she was uh look it up
secretary now someone's someone's going
to chat it we're gonna we're gonna get
it yeah she's the voice of Katara on uh
an avatar The Last Airbender I'm waiting
for someone to give me the answer but
there's like a minute lag or whatever
did you find out May Whitman Mae Whitman
right she was the originally the little
girl in Independence Day and they recast
her because they were like we want you
know an attractive woman and they
considered her frumpy I guess or
whatever
that's how Hollywood works man
that's how Hollywood Works Logan says so
many 20s tonight I know it's a good time
great show critical success a lot of
ones as well a lot of people didn't
really agree on a lot of things play
hard Pollyanna forever says finally saw
Freedom tunes and The Crazy Chicken show
Epic yo we're consistently getting
around like 200 concurrent viewers on
chicken City live thank you when we run
these commercials on Tucker it's going
to be epic so we have a functional
functional commercial but it's a good
commercial and that's the problem it
like accurately advertises chicken City
and it says go to the website it shows
the chickens and it shows them running
around and I'm like no no the commercial
needs to be stupid it needs to be like
us arguing with the chickens like
dramatic scenes the users roosters like
chasing after us at fake explosions take
me back like on my knees begging for
forgiveness oh yeah we we need one wrong
we need like five seconds of Ian
explaining graphene to the chickens yeah
as they all sit around you like I'll
give you an hour you can just cut cut
the five seconds
chickens Listen by the way I want to
thank you for finally watching Freedom
Tunes they finally watched it and you
can too go over to youtube.com freedoms
right now subscribe hit the notification
Bell we got some more cartoons coming I
think you guys are gonna love them
son of man says Ian is the smartest guy
because he thinks outside the
conventional box you all need to leave
him alone
intelligence is weirdly defined I'm just
I'm a piece of a puzzle so in the wrong
puzzle I don't fit I just happen to kind
of fit in this one also Ian doesn't want
to be left alone he wants to discuss
these things he wants to argue he wants
to have his view challenge you know me
yeah exactly Ian's the Wild Card man let
me have it he often says things that
make us all question the the uh our
preconceived uh conceptions our
preconceptions
or pre-kenosha question yourself but
don't question yourself too much I made
that mistake and it can drive you insane
so you have to find a reality that you
enjoy and then find a community that
agrees with it and then work together
stay grounded
all right we can only we'll just grab a
couple more here because we actually
have to get in the car we're driving out
to Nashville literally right now
so let's just grab a couple here
all right Tommy Boy says how do you feel
about jenseki potentially going to MSNBC
to me it seems like it's going to be a
complete and absolute dumpster fire does
she even have any journalism experience
I don't care
um I expect it I mean Sean Spicer he
went to Newsmax right yeah he did
whatever yeah Sarah Sanders yeah Jen's
yeah where did she go to Fox yeah yeah
going to MSNBC I'm just like that's
exactly what MSNBC is you it's partisan
they love it yeah we know Sean Spicer
into news max it's partisan they love it
it's you know the Press secretaries
aren't uh um
this is their pundits it's what they do
they spin they spin on behalf of the
White House yeah no they can do that
yeah exactly they'll do the same thing I
don't watch that stuff you know I I
think Sean Spicer is better in a lot of
ways than Jen sackey but I think in
terms of skill gensak he's pretty good
at a job yeah she can spin man that's
her job yeah I mean you know and she
does it and everyone rolls their eyes
but when they make fun of her being
Circle back Jen I'm like you realize
that works for the establishment press
right she ignores questions and they
never question it she's she's got him
wrapped up you know she knows how to
manipulate but you know I will I will be
fair it's easy when the Press is already
in the bag for you so
she can stand there and do nothing and
then she grumbles because she calls on
Peter Ducey as like the token
conservative guy I think
yep it's great all right here's uh
here's we got a couple more the base was
it the base badass I'm running for Texas
State Senate in San Antonio I just
wanted to thank everyone for the
encouragement and inspiration to run hey
right on man but we don't have your name
so uh but good luck yeah good luck and
last we'll read this one Chris Adkins
says I am volciferon follower of the
Beanie and woofer shirt of chicken City
congratulations good sir all right
everybody if you haven't already you
must smash the like button do it for Ian
if Ian doesn't get 10 000 likes he'll
cry but if James will get mad he'll cry
and then Sheamus is punching holes in
walls and then Ian is crying and then I
got I gotta deal with it and then oh man
you know I can literally I can hear it
from the other room I'm not able to fall
asleep because Ian's bawling his eyes
out and he starts crying even harder if
you're working out I told you that if
you listen really really carefully in
Freedom Tunes you can actually hear Ian
crying in the background half the time
and crunches I'm doing crunches come on
go to timcast.com become a member uh
help support our work you all of our our
whole library of members only segments
are available you can search for people
and watch all this awesome stuff you can
also check out chicken City right now
the chickens are sleeping but if you go
to youtube.com chicken City you can
watch that but also check out pop
culture crisis uh which is just search
YouTube for pop culture crisis subscribe
it's uh mostly cultural uh topics but
it's a similar style podcast hosted by
Brett dasovic and uh we're going to be
doing a bunch of promotion for that
relatively soon because the show's you
know gotten its footing and it's and
it's growing and getting more views so
we're gonna start promoting it so check
that out you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me at timcast
Oren do you want to shout anything out
yeah definitely uh make sure to check
out my YouTube channel Oren McIntyre uh
on Twitter I think on Twitter I've got
the the link tree or the find my friends
where you can find all my stuff I've got
channels on Odyssey and Rumble I've got
uh subscribe star all that stuff so go
ahead and follow me there
nice I run a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes who make cartoons I think
you guys are gonna like them go check
that out you know subscribe hit the
notification Bell or Ian will cry again
the like button find the white pill it's
in you man you got it that's right you
got it there bye do that he's already
fighting back tears we're a thousand
likes away it's natural we got this oh
and we're gonna be driving to Nashville
he's gonna be crying though I'm gonna be
checking the video and watching the
comments all night you guys so keep
making them I'm gonna get a call from
Sheamus and I'm gonna answer it and I'm
just gonna hear
here's the thing like I know punching
the walls is only gonna make him cry
harder but I I'm so angry at that point
that self-destruction is perfectly
acceptable man it's just I got pads for
the walls sound pads yeah yeah we we are
all in padded rooms over here anyway you
guys should check out pop culture crisis
because I am on there every Wednesday
except this Wednesday so if you like
what I have to say go check it out Brett
is an awesome uh host and he does a
great job researching for the show you
guys may follow me on Twitter at sour
patchlitz I'm also on minds.com and I
also have sour patch lids.me so follow
me on all those spots we will see all of
you over at timcast.com or chicken City
and we'll be in Nashville all next week
we're actually going to be there first
thing in the morning because we're
driving all throughout the night and
then I guess not sleeping I guess and
then I have to work through the weekend
because that's the point of being down
there to do work so uh that'll be fun
but um maybe maybe we'll see you around
in Nashville thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time bye guys